[musique]
Patrick Martin, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? D'abord
Patrick Martin effectivement euh bientôt
66 ans, père de famille, trois enfants,
trois filles que j'adore, chef
d'entreprise, passionné par l'entreprise
et puis à mes moments perdus qui sont
assez nombreux, président du MEDEF.
C'est quoi le MEDEF ?
Malmeddev, c'est un collectif avant tout
qui regroupe 2400 entreprises, des
petites, des grandes, des moyennes dans
tous les secteurs d'activité, sur tout
le territoire national et c'est un lobby
et on assume totalement d'être un lobby.
Puis par ailleurs, on a un rôle plus
institutionnel, légal de négociateur
social.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler France,
business, patron, guerre économique,
Union européenne, budget, plein de
sujets.
On va creuser le cerveau. Patrick,
première question, est-ce que nos boîtes
sont en danger par une inconséquence de
notre gouvernement incapable
d'encaisser, de faire de l'anticipation
pour protéger nos boîtes ? Où est-ce que
nos chefs d'entreprise pour maintenir
leur marge ont décidé de se barrer parce
que ils sont pas patriote.
Alors nos boîtes pour beaucoup d'entre
elles sont en danger. pas du seul fait
de ce gouvernement dont les marges de
manœuvre sont incroyablement étroites
mais qui n'a pas pris les bonnes
décisions de mon point de vue mais
également du fait d'une Union européenne
qui d'abord sous-estime sa puissance et
est très inerte au regard de toutes ces
menaces qui s'accumulent et de ces
offensives qui sont lancées par des
grandes puissances étrangères. Donc nous
au milieu, on navigue, on est résilient
comme on dit maintenant mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a de grosses inquiétudes dans de
plus en plus de secteurs d'activité.
On peut délayer ici, on a le temps. Je
peux je peux délayer.
OK. Les boîtes. Non mais moi je dél
hein.
Non bah vas-y dél parce que
non moi je suis je suis très frappé à
vrai dire très inquiet de voir que
particulièrement en France il y a une
méconnaissance de ce qui se passe à la
surface du globe. Il y a une espèce de
de nombrilisme. Je suis lyonnais hein.
Ça cuchonne. On dit ça comme ça à Lyon.
Ça veut dire que il y a un entre soi euh
avec des logiques, avec des des
arrangements qui peut-être se défendent
mais qui sont tellement éloignés de ce
que de notre point de vue, du point de
vue du MDAF, il faudrait faire,
c'est-à-dire se mettre au niveau de la
compétition internationale pour
commencer sur le plan technologique mais
également sur le plan des compétences,
enfin dans un certain nombre de
compartiments du jeu. Et donc si nos
politiques ne remettent pas les pieds
sur terre, ne vont pas un peu plus à
l'étranger. Moi, je suis très frappé par
ça et je
aller à l'étranger.
Bah, tout simplement se déplacer, aller
en Chine. Moi, je suis curieux de savoir
parmi nos gouvernants combien combien
sont allés en Chine, mettons même ces 10
dernières années. Je parle de la Chine,
ça peut être vrai des États-Unis, mais
ça peut être vrai de l'Afrique et
cetera. Et donc, je pense que ils ont
une une compréhension, une appréhension
un peu livresque, un peu théorique, un
peu horsol de la rudesse, de la violence
de cette compétition, mais également des
opportunités incroyables qui existent.
Donc voilà, c'est le nez sur le guidon.
Euh c'est des petits arrangements entre
amis, y compris de la part de gens qui
sont éminemment estimables, mais mais
euh mais qui ne voit pas les choses
comme elles sont.
Donc ici euh en face de vous, de toi, il
y a que des patrons et donc tu es un peu
notre syndicaliste.
Ouais.
Donc on va te rentrer dans le larve
aujourd'hui.
Vas-y. [rires]
Question guerre économique. On connaît
un peu le secteur, on connaît un peu les
grosses boîtes qui traînent là-dedans
censé défendre et anticiper les grandes
tendances. Moi, je vais poser une
question qui va être très claire et très
directe. Le MEDEF quand il voit notre
gouvernement naviguer selon le sens du
vent, à vue, borgne, ce que tu veux,
est-ce que le MDEF par souci de
robustesse et de résilience doté d'un
sink tank ou d'une cellule de
prospective pour sentir le vent beaucoup
plus loin, avoir une vision beaucoup
plus perforante ? En gros, est-ce que le
MEDF a une pointe de diamant pour se
voir un cap plus profond que notre
gouvernement ? et surtout protéger nos
boîtes, anticiper et ensuite aller à
l'attaque, avancer en meute.
Alors déjà, je rebondis sur ce que je te
disais avant. Euh nous, on a des
capteurs à l'international qui sont
assez extraordinaires par nos boîtes,
mais également par notre propre
organisation. Donc je pense qu'on a une
compréhension du monde en temps réel qui
est meilleure en tout cas que celle de
beaucoup de nos nos politiques. Ensuite
en terme d'organisation, on a mis en
place par exemple il y a 8 ans, 7 ans
euh une commission souveraineté et
sécurité économique. À l'époque quand on
a mis ça en place, ça a suscité des
interrogations, y compris des soupçons
de gens qui disaient "Mais qu'est-ce qu'
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont ? Ils deviennent
souverainistes ?
Ils sont ils sont en train de de
promouvoir une forme de repli sur soi.
C'était absolument pas l'enjeu. L'enjeu
au contraire, c'était d'avoir de manière
plus structurée, je dire plus
conceptuelle et plus systématique une
approche qui prenne en compte ces
menaces. Alors, malheureusement, en un
sens, les faits nous ont donné raison
parce que quand je dis il y a 7 ans, ben
le monde il y a 7 ans, c'était pas le
monde d'aujourd'hui hein euh entre
l'Ukraine, entre les tensions entre euh
la Chine et Taiwan, entre les
changements de gouvernement aux
États-Unis, euh même si la pente était
déjà celle-là, hein, euh mais enfin, il
y a une accélération, une accentuation
assez brutale et assez inquiétante de de
la menace américaine. Je ne pense pas
que du mal des États-Unis, mais quand
même, il y a une menace américaine de
l'avant. Donc voilà, je vais pas dire
qu'on a une précience, mais on s'est
armé en quelque sorte pour au-delà de ce
qu'on faisait traditionnellement euh
avoir cette cette intelligence des
choses. Pas moi, le MDEF.
OK. Le groupe en question s'est composé
comment, par qui, par quoi ? Quelles
sont les sondes, combien de fois ça se
réunit ? Il y a combien de groupes
est-ce que leur prospective, leur
rapport n'ont pas fait chou blanc ?
Est-ce que leur rapports ont laissé des
traces efficaces ?
Oui, absolument. Alors, d'abord pour
pour
imager en quelque sorte ou incarner
d'une certaine manière mon propos,
typiquement le le fondateur de cette
commission qui continue à la présider,
c'est l'ancien numéro 2 de la DGA, donc
un ingénieur général de l'armement donc
avec cette sensibilité singulière, y
compris en matière militaire, en matière
de technologie. Et puis bon, on a on a
près de 300 personnes qui participent à
ces travaux.
C'est un peu l'ADN du MEDF avec des
profils très différents en terme
d'expertise, en terme de parcours
professionnel, en terme de sensibilité
même. Et puis cette cette commission,
c'est en tout cas le l'organisation
qu'on a au MEDF, ça n'est pas un silo.
On s'applique à ce qu'elle elle soit en
relation permanente avec toutes nos
autres commissions. par exemple, on a
des des enjeux de de fiscalité au niveau
international qui relèvent pas
statutairement, je dirais, de cette
commission souveraineté et sécurité
économique, mais euh ces enjeux de
fiscalité sont pris en compte. Tous les
enjeux de technologie, on a une
commission innovation, euh tous les
enjeux de technologie sont euh croisés
en quelque sorte avec euh les approches
et les et les perspectives de cette
commission souveraineté et sécurité
économique. Je suis pas en train de dire
qu'on a inventé la poudre, je suis pas
en train de dire qu'on est omniscient,
mais enfin quand même, on est très
attentif à tous ces enjeux et chaque
jour un peu plus nécessité fait loi. Et
puis je le redis, on a quand même toutes
nos connexions alors à l'international
parce que des relations très suivies,
très construites avec nos homologues,
mes homologues prioritairement européens
mais par exemple africains, on a
développé une alliance des patronats
francophones qui n'est pas que tourné
vers l'Afrique mais en bonne part quand
même mais ça nous donne des connexions
avec le Canada, avec le le Cambodge, le
Vietnam et cetera. Et enfin, on a notre
bras armé qui est MEDF international où
à longueur d'année, on fait venir des
délégations étrangères où on envoie à
l'étranger des délégations et à chaque
fois, on a des remontées d'informations
qui nous permettent donc d'affiner en
quelque sorte notre compréhension du
monde.
Tu as dit une phrase qui a qui m'a piqué
l'oreille.
On va là où nécessité fait loi.
Ouais. Tu connais le proverbe, c'est le
proverbe de la DGSE, là où nécessité
fait loin. Quand on voit aux États-Unis
que les boîtes américaines sont baqué
par un les tribunaux américains de les
services de renseignement américain, moi
je vais te poser une question. Est-ce
que nos boîtes françaises ont compris ?
Je pense qu'elles ont compris, mais
est-ce que nos services ont compris
qu'il fallait un petit peu épauler nos
boîtes françaises pour éviter des
phénomènes de chantage à l'étranger, des
phénomènes de chantage que ce soit
fiscal, de mafia, de collusion, de
pénétration par des groupes bizarres
comme Ipstein et Touti.
Est-ce que toi au MEDF, on a fait une
interview de ton prédécesseur
que tu étais son bras droit, monsieur
Rout Bieux qu'on qu'on embrasse. Est-ce
que OMEDF tu as repris les choses
pareilles ? C'est-à-dire nos services
avancent comme des raptors pour protéger
nos boîtes et donc notre PIB.
Ouais. Alors c'est historique en tout
cas, c'est longue date pour nos grosses
boîtes et les plus évidemment exposées
technologiquement.
Euh moi ce que j'observe et on y
contribue hein, c'est que d'oren avant
on descend à la fois sur des tailles
d'entreprises moins importante mais
sensible pour autant sensible ne
serait-ce qu'en tant que sous-traitante
de des majors qui déjà été suivis et
puis en terme de secteur d'activité il y
a un élargissement du spectre te dire
que on est abouti non mais par exemple
sur les enjeux de de cyber on connaît
toutes les toutes les formes de la cyber
c'est c'est pas forcément de
l'espionnage de l'étatique et cetera et
hein.
On a on a un gros travail avec les
différentes agences au services de
l'État pour faire de la sensibilisation,
de la formation de de l'équipement, de
la mesure. Après, c'est le pro du MDF.
Nous, on n'est pas hiérarchique par
rapport à nos 2400 entreprises
adhérentes, mais on fait un énorme
effort dans ce sens-là. Et moi ce que je
mesure, c'est que au fil des ans, il y a
une sensibilité croissante des chefs
d'entreprise, des entreprises
elles-mêmes à tous ces enjeux.
Tu tu me dis que nos services nous
baquent, que il y a une bonne dynamique.
Toi, en tant que président du MEDF,
quand tu vois les États-Unis racheter
les bijoux de famille français menaçant
notre souveraineté, quand tu vois le
pouvoir politique
soit brader le nos boîtes, soit vendre
nos boîtes sans aucun prisme de lecture
à moyen et court terme, qu'est-ce que tu
en penses ? C'est ce que le MEDF a son
mot à dire en disant voilà bon vous
voyez pas le truc venir mais le
sous-traitant machin il bosse avec le
rafale la boîte qui pourrait miner du
Bitcoin
ce serait peut-être intéressant pour
nous pour nos boîtes pour notre industri
pour notre PIB ou quoi que ce soit.
Est-ce que le MEDEF arrive à discuter
avec notre gouvernement où ils sont
totalement en sol avec le monde de
l'entreprise ? Écoute, je vais te
répondre par un détour.
ligne droite et tu fais du rugby. Donc
si tu fais un détour, ça me laisse le
temps de me lancer, hein.
Un changement de pied. Euh
euh non, en te disant d'abord qu'on est
les derniers des annes au niveau
européen, au niveau français parce
queune des raisons principales du rachat
d'un certain nombre de nos boîtes pour
certaines hypersensibles, c'est qu'on a
été incapable incapable de draîner
l'épargne hyper abondante de l'Europe.
Finalement, le le la force principale de
l'Europe, c'est d'être très excédentaire
en épargne, là où les États-Unis, en
particulier sont très déficitaires. Mais
ce pognon part à raison de 300 milliards
d'euros par an vers les États-Unis. Et
donc après, tu as des enjeux de
valorisation. C'est la règle du jeu. Tu
as tu as une boîte qui se vend, tu as un
acquéreur. C'est celui qui met le plus
sur la table qui en logique purement
commerciale emporte le morceau. Donc si
déjà on commençait par le commencement,
c'est-à-dire se doter des moyens
financiers pour d'abord financer le
développement de ces boîtes et le jour
venu les faire racheter par des acteurs
français et européens plutôt que chinois
ou américains, ça serait déjà pas mal.
Bon après nous on n' pas de de
légitimité pour te dire très franchement
on n pas d'organisation structurée pour
systématiquement échanger avec les
pouvoirs public sur la dangerosité en
tout cas sur le risque d'une acquisition
de de boîte par un prédateur y compris
américain.
C'est peut-être temps de faire un petit
peu sécession de ce côté-là non ? faire
un fond souverain, piloter par le MEDF,
protéger nos boîtes, avancer en phalange
et aller à l'attaque.
Oui. Euh alors ça renvoie à plein de
sujets. Bon,
mais tu as cru que tu étais venu pour
pousser un cad ? Non non mais je je
je peux te parler longuement et je le
ferai volontiers de de l'impérieuse
nécessité y compris de ce point de vue
d'avoir des des retraites par
capitalisation parce que on sait très
bien ce qui donne ce qui alimente les
fonds souverains. Alors quand on n pas
de de gaz, on n'est pas en Norvège donc
on n pas un fond souverain qui est qui
est par centaines de milliards d'euros
est alimenté par des ressources
naturelles. Mais donc c'est par les
retraites par capitalisation que
d'urgence. Il faut maintenant qu'on on
se dote de capitaux. Mais en amon de
tout ça, il faut d'abord que les
entreprises européennes et françaises
soient plus rentables parce que l'argent
ira là où il est le plus rentable. Donc
ouais, nous on est très on est très
moteur sur ce sujet-là et moi j'observe
ce qu'il faut être optimiste, hein.
J'observe qu'il y a des sujets qui
étaient complètement tabou il y a
quelques mois encore ou quelques années
encore. Typiquement les retraites par
capitalisation qui dorent avant par
nécessité d'une certaine manière, mais
aussi parce qu'on a fait un gros travail
de pédagogie nous le MEDEF. euh sont
diabolisés. Donc je pense qu'on va finir
par y arriver et y compris en terme de
souveraineté, c'est très important. Moi
je suis très frappé par ça. On accle
certaines entreprises côté par exemple
au motif que elles arbitreraient leurs
investissements au bénéfice d'autres
pays que la France. Ouais. Enfin, tu
peux pas demander une entreprise dont le
capital est majoritairement détenu par
des actionnaires étrangers anglo-saxon
ou pas. C'est pas la question d'être un
patriote français. Donc mettons un peu
de cohérence, un peu de logique, un peu
de volontarisme dans ces sujets-là
plutôt que d'être dans le commentaire
systématiquement critique et accablant.
Tu parles de ressources naturelles, tu
faisais euh peut-être référence à la
Norvège ou un fond souverain norvégien
ou finlandais peut-être. Euh et tu
parles de rentabilité.
Quand tu vois euh euh notre gouvernement
ne pas comprendre la relation de cause à
effet entre le prix énergétique et la
rentabilité de nos boîtes,
tu les regardes comme si c'était des
demeurés qui ne connaissent rien. Tu les
regardes comme des illuminés.
L'énergie c'est le sang des entreprises.
Quand tu vois que le coût énergétique de
nos boîtes explose, que même le
boulanger d'en face la la grise mine
parce que ces factures d'électricité
explosent. Quand tu vois nos industries
énergivor au possible
commencer à tirer la langue d'une façon
très forte. Tu parles aussi de l'Europe,
regarde ce qui se passe en Allemagne
avec leur grosse boîte. Quand tu vois
une Union européenne avoir un prisme de
lecture sans aucune profondeur, sans
connaître les bases de nos sociétés
thermo-industrielles,
quand tu es patron que tu connais un
minimum le tissu de nos industries, tu
les vois s'agiter, faire du bruit avec
leur bouche et et faire de l'air avec
leurs bras, vous avez pas eu peur de
voir ces gens-là commencer à ne pas
anticiper les choses ?
Euh
allez, je je
je pense qu'il y a un vrai sujet de de
d'évaluation des politiques publiques et
au-delà de ça de responsabilité des
décideurs publics. C'est quand même
assez hallucinant de voir que par
exemple il y a eu un emballement autour
du Green Deal européen. Alors, c'était
tout le monde il est beau, tout le monde
il est gentil et la moindre voix
dissonnante était immédiatement
stigmatisée
et soupçonné de négationnisme, de déni
climatique. Enfin, des trucs
incroyables. Je je cite cet exemple,
mais tu évoquais plus précisément
l'énergie. Quand on voit le
l'irrationalité ou en tout cas la
manipulation du débat sur la
programmation pluriéannuelle de
l'énergie en France, c'est complètement
dingue. Chacun est dans une posture et à
un moment donné et je prétends pas que
le MEDF détient la vérité hein, mais on
essaie de participer à la
rationalisation, à l'objectivation des
débats et ben ça devient impossible.
Impossible parce que tel camp politique,
tel parti politique a décidé qu'il était
pour le nucléaire. point final. Tel
autre a décidé qu'il était pour les
énergies renouvelables point final. Et
c'est des c'est c'est devenu des enjeux
de positionnement électoral. Donc et
c'est vrai de tellement d'autres sujets,
les accords de libre échange par
exemple. Donc euh nous on se désespère
mais on ne se résigne pas. On se
désespère de voir que singulièrement en
France, mais un peu au niveau européen,
on on ne sait plus poser les sujets de
manière d'abord sereine, respectueuse,
mais surtout objective pour ensuite les
traiter. Et donc à un moment donné euh
on découvre le poteau rose alors que les
choses étaient inscrites et alors de
manière plus ou moins piteuse, on
C'est quoi le poteau rose ? Pas lepot
rose, c'est queon a pris des décisions
publiques au motif de de raisonnement
purement politicien euh et que euh le
jour assez rapidement souvent où on
découvre qu'en réalité c'était
totalement inapproprié à bas bruit, euh
en détournant le le regard, on détour on
détricote tout ça sans trop l'avouer
mais tout en le faisant. Si tu prends en
France le le le cas d'une loi, je sais
pas si ça parle à tout le monde, d'une
loi dite climat et résilience qui a mis
en place le zéro artificialisation
nette, le zones à faible émission,
l'obligation de rénovation thermique des
logements, les intentions, on les
partageait très sincèrement. Les
modalités, les calendriers, c'était une
vue de l'esprit. Bon, mais moi, je me
souviens très bien avoir émis quelques
réserves beaucoup de précautions, mais
c'est séance tenant, j'étais cloué au
pilorie. Ce type n'a rien compris. Ce
type est climatoceptique. Ce type veut
la mort de l'humanité. Euh les gens qui
vont rentrer dans les zones à faible
émission avec leurs 205 diesel critère 5
sont des assassins. Donc on est parti
dans des délires et moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé à l'époque c'est que y
compris des parlementaires ou plus
généralement des décideurs politiques en
âme et conscience étaient d'accord mais
ont voté ce texte-là de peur d'être
eux-mêmes cloués au pilorie livré à la
vanicte populaire à des ONG hyper
militantes. Moi, j'ai pas j'ai rien
contre le principe des ONG, mais il y en
a qui sont quand même très très
militantes et assez sectaires
et avec financement extérieur et avec
des financements extérieurs, ça oui,
c'est un autre point, j'y reviendrai.
Euh et donc euh à quelques années
d'intervalle
et bien on se dit le zéro
artificialisation nette, c'est pas tout
à fait ça parce que les gens qui peuvent
pas se loger en centre-ville ne peuvent
pas non plus se loger en grande
périphérie.
parce que on veut réindustrialiser mais
non mais finalement il y a plus de
foncier pour implanter ou agrandir des
usines et tout quantti donc
et ça dégénère complètement t tous les
débats de renavant mais c'est
probablement vrai aux États-Unis en pire
peut-être mais tous les débats de
renavant sont complètement biaisés et je
reviens sur le les ONG à nouveau je
garde d'en faire une généralité hein.
Alors c'est des ONG ou des associations
de circonstances qui émergent comme ça.
On sait pas trop d'où, on sait pas trop
comment. Nous, notre demande, elle est
très claire, elle n'est pas populaire
mais je m'en fiche, c'est que on
applique à ces ONG les mêmes règles de
transparence qui légalement s'imposent
aux entreprises et à nos organisations.
Le le MEDF est passé au crime, le
radarisé dans tous les sens, tous les
jours et à la limite, on s'en accommode.
La transparence c'est pas c'est pas
criticable. Il faut de la transparence.
Mais il y a vraiment deux poids de
mesure et je continue de me lâcher. Euh
tu avais commencé à te lâcher là ?
Ouais ouais. Euh il y a une ONG euh
européenne euh Transparency
International qui nous a décerné le
titre infamant au MEDF de le plus
influent à Bruxelles. Alors moi je à
partir de là, j'aurais dû raser les
murs, passer sous la table, bah rien du
tout. Moi, je suis ravi que le MEDF soit
identifié comme le lobby le plus
influent à Bruxelles. Parce que moi, je
suis pour le débat, je suis même pour la
confrontation mais ça peut pas être à
sens unique. Et donc voilà, je pense
qu'on souffre d'une espèce de de de
politiquement correct qui nous conduit
pas systématiquement mais dans un
certain nombre de cas qu'on vient
d'évoquer à faire des conneries, autant
ne pas les faire.
On va revenir sur le fait qu'un chef
d'entreprise a besoin d'un cap, d'être
éclairé, d'avoir des oreilles, le nez un
peu et des yeux partout. Revenons au
coup de Bruxelles.
Donc le MEDF va se frotter aux autres
lobby à Bruxelles. Est-ce que vous
graissez des pattes un peu comme les
autres lobbyes ? Vous payez des chambres
garnies, vous payez des coups ? Comment
ça se passe ?
Mais non,
merde.
Et alors toi, j'ai été préalablement
trésorier du MDEF. Je l'aurais su. Non,
j'ai pas vu passer. D'abord, il y a
peut-être pas de facture dans ces
cas-là, mais bon, j'ai rien vu passer de
tel. Non, non, mais on fait on fait euh
euh comme nos petits camarades de jeu,
hein, on fait un boulot de de euh de de
conviction, de documentation, mais
surtout il faut identifier le plus en
amont le plus en amont possible les les
sujets parce que après quand ça rentre
dans les arcanes Bruxelloises, euh c'est
c'est intraçable parce que on se plaint
de l'administration française parfois de
manière excessive, elle est assez
opaque. Elle a en partie échappé au
contrôle du politique, ce qui est d'un
point de vue démocratique et en terme
d'efficacité assez désolant. Mais alors
à Bruxelles, c'est puissance 10. Donc
voilà, il faut il faut être à la fois
très systématique, très mobile, avoir je
crois que tu aimes les chiens la truffe
humide, c'est-à-dire
flairer les les opportunités, flairer
les menaces et et être
euh sur la balle.
Oui, j'aime les chiens et les chiens.
Euh j'aime surtout les chiens de garde,
les chiens qui protègent et qui savent
identifier les menaces et qui ne vont
pas mordre par peur, mais qui vont
mordre pour neutraliser
nos boîtes. Est-ce que tu as identifié
des vélociraptors qui ont un cerveau,
qui ont la capacité à sentir les
tendances et qui ont cette capacité à
anticiper
qui pour toi en France fait ce boulot là
de Raptor avec le nez humide ? l'œil
qui
bah je pense que et
c'est vraiment très bien ainsi, on a
dans le secteur de la défense, dans
l'aéronautique, dans le naval, des
boîtes qui sont qui sont extraordinaires
parce que quand on voit les budgets
militaires français jusqu'à une période
récente, mais encore aujourd'hui avec
leur augmentation, relativement c'est
assez dérisoire par rapport au budget
d'autres grands pays. Je pense
évidemment aux États-Unis, mais la Chine
et même la Russie d'une certaine
manière. Donc c'est extraordinaire qu'on
ait su préserver et développer ces ces
savoir-fa. Et donc en matière de
technologie, on a on a des des boîtes
les les majeurs bien sûr, on a tous les
noms en tête, les Talès, les Safran, les
Dassau, les Naval Group et cetera. en
total
en total dans dans un genre différent
hein euh mais qui sont euh qui sont
vraiment des des référence mondiale et
euh
qui qui sur le plan technologique sont
absolument extraordinaires. Mais on a
derrière un foisonnement de d'abord de
sous-traitants de start-up incroyable.
Moi, je suis très admiratif quand on va
dans les salons professionnels de voir
que oui, il y a des offres incroyables
de des Israéliens,
des Chinois si on les laisse apparaître
dans ces salons. Euh mais franchement,
on doit sonorer de de ce qu'on a réussi
à maintenir, à développer en la matière.
Dans l'aéronautique, on est civil avec
Arbus qui n'est pas que français, enfin
largement français quand même. On a on a
des trucs de dingue. Il faut absolument
les préserver. Bon, après, il y a il y a
d'autres il y a d'autres secteurs où
pour différentes raisons, je les
identifie pas toutes, on a été en bonne
part mis dans le vent euh typiquement
dans le numérique. Dans le numérique,
euh dans la téléphonie d'une certaine
manière, je parle pas des opérateurs, je
parle des industriels, des développeurs.
Et là euh on est à ce jour, on est
largué. Donc si oninvestit pas
massivement sur des technologies de
rupture dans la dans le quantique
notamment, on a vraiment du souci à se
faire parce que ce sont des industries
et des technologies souveraines. Voilà,
donc il y a du il y a du bon et du moins
bon. Moi, je suis pas du tout résigné.
Je pense que si on a des stratégies
industrielles et technologiques beaucoup
mieux identifiées, beaucoup mieux
ciblées et qu'on met en face les moyens
alors les moyens financiers bien sûr,
mais surtout les moyens humains, on a on
a en Europe, on a en France encore de
belles opportunités.
Qui c'est qui fait la stratégie en
France ?
C'est une excellente question.
C'est une excellente question à laquelle
je ne sais pas répondre.
Tu vois les conséquences ? Mais bien
sûr. Non, mais le le le la caricature
c'est l'énergie quoi. Enfin, c'est quand
même complètement dingue qu'on a eu ces
changements de pieds, ses volt euh sur
une industrie très consommatrice de
capitaux euh qui engage des
investissements sur des décennies et euh
que pour des raisons euh assez
politiciennes en définitive sur le
nucléaire en particulier,
on est on est on a donc eu ces
changements de pied. Enfin, c'est quand
même complètement dingue euh de rappeler
parce que beaucoup l'ont en tête, tu
l'as en tête que euh jusqu'à la
publication de ce décret PPE3 euh on
était dans l'illégalité. Je veux dire
par là qu'on était sous le coût de la
PPE 2, la programmation pluriéannuelle
de l'énergie 2 qui prévoyait la
fermeture de 14 réacteurs nucléaires.
Pour autant, on a lancé le premier EPR,
on a réussi à le financer plus ou moins
malgré les dépassements de budget. Très
bien. Mais on était dans une forme de de
déni ou d'abration. Donc euh ouais, il y
a une cruelle impérieuse nécessité
d'avoir des stratégies. Alors ça semble
se dessiner un petit peu au niveau
européen, mais c'est lent, c'est lourd,
c'est inerte. Au niveau français, il
faut vraiment qu'on y revienne très
vite.
Tu sais ce que c'est un protozo ?
Oui.
Il y a une moelle épinière dans le
protozoer.
Je ne crois pas.
Ouais. Est-ce que nous on a une moelle
épinière pour prendre des décisions ?
Par exemple, un commissaire au plan à 30
ans parce que quand tu vois Macron
débarquer pour des questions électorales
dire bon je vais faire mes 14 réacteurs,
nous on bosse sur l'énergie depuis 2005.
On s'est dit mais elle est où la
Mépinière ?
C'est pas Macron qui a décidé de de
fermer
ou c'était Hollande.
C'était Hollande.
Mais il a continué.
Bah il a il a mis en œuvre la fermeture
de Fesson mais qui qui une erreur
fatale.
Ouais. On avait la la la centrale
rénovée, propre
et puis pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle était à
la frontière allemande. Donc les
Allemands commençaient à dire,
je pense qu' alors je
donc parlons-moi les pinières de CAP de
commissariat au plan. Euh je je je ne
sais pas je ne crois pas à vrai dire
qu'on puisse fonctionner, qu'on a très
bien fonctionné une époque avec le plan
et avec une autorité de l'État qui était
une pertinence de l'État qui de mon
point de vue ont disparu. Il y a une
forme de popérisation de la pensée de
d'État qui est assez incroyable du côté
des politiques eux même, mais également
du côté de la haute administration parce
que parce que on a tellement dénigré ces
gens-là, on les a tellement mis sous
contrainte que en définitive
la politique n'est plus très attractive.
Faut faut être sacrificiel
pour faire de la politique maintenant ou
alors ne pas savoir faire ou ne pas
savoir faire autre chose.
Euh bon euh parce que tu en prends plein
la gueule, tu gagnes pas un fifrelin, tu
as un risque réputationnel permanent, un
risque judiciaire permanent, tu es
soumis à des règles notamment de la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique qui sont absolument
infernales. Enfin faut avoir faut être
inconscient euh ou euh très
ou très patriote et heureusement on a
encore des gens comme ça.
Mais je pense quand même que il n cumule
des mandats, pardon d'être dans des
considérations très opérationnelles.
Mais je pense que ça a détourné un
certain nombre de gens de valeur de
l'engagement politique et qu'on a pas
d'une manière systématique mais quand
même on a une forme d'appauvrissement du
niveau de notre personnel politique.
Bien euh et il en va même de la haute
fonction publique. la
la fonction publique d'une manière
générale est mal gérée et le prestige en
définitive de certaines certaines
fonctions administratives c'est
totalement dissipé. Donc là aussi, il
faut être faut avoir le sens de l'État
au berceau pour pour s'annoncer
làdedans. beaucoup de respect pour
beaucoup de fonctionnaires. Mais enfin
si on se remémore qui était les patrons
de DF, les les ceux qui ont conduit le
programme nucléaire, qui on conduit le
programme TGV,
ben voilà les les infrastructures
routières et autoroutières, enfin il y
avait du côté politique et du côté haute
administration les ingénieurs des ponts,
c'était c'était l'aristocratie et ces
gens-là, on les respectait infiniment,
les ingénieurs des mines, enfin bon.
Alors nouveau, je ne dénigre pas ceux
qui sont en place aujourd'hui, mais en
terme de puissance, en terme d'ora, en
terme de prestige et en terme de
pouvoir, ils ont beaucoup perdu. À
partir de là, je pense que c'est très
difficile d'avoir au seul niveau
étatique une vraie stratégie. Et puis on
a perdu, faut dire les choses, moi je
suis très très européiste, mais on a
perdu également beaucoup de leviers
typiquement sur la tarification de
l'énergie ou même le le choix technique.
Tu es resté très européiste avec ça.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais mais bon moi je
n'oublie pas pour autant qu' il y a pas
si longtemps au titre de la taxonomie,
on était à deux doigts de ne plus
pouvoir financer le nucléaire de la même
manière qu'on était à deux doigts de ne
plus pouvoir financer l'armement. Alors
bon, les circonstances malheureuses
d'une certaine manière ont permis quand
même de corriger le tir. Mais euh et
donc on a objectivement on a perdu de
l'autonomie ou de l'indépendance sur un
certain nombre de de décisions
stratégiques. Euh ça veut dire qu'il
faut que l'Europe assume de son côté ce
qui n'est pas assez le cas aujourd'hui.
Là où je voulais en venir, c'est que
dans dans ce monde qui est devenu
beaucoup plus ouvert, beaucoup plus
mobile, beaucoup plus aléatoire,
beaucoup plus technologique, je pense
que l'État se porterait bien de faire
beaucoup plus confiance au secteur privé
plutôt que de devoir arbitrer jusque
dans les moindres détails des choix qui
sont pas éclairés au bout du compte.
s'il y avait ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui une confiance une confiance
en réalité entre les pouvoirs
politiques. Je parle du national, c'est
beaucoup moins vrai au niveau local
heureusement mais entre le politique et
le monde économique d'une manière
générale, les entreprises au premier
chef, mais ça peut être des économistes
et cetera, on s'emporterait bien sans
faire des grands machins de recréer le
commissariat au plan d'une époque. Mais
voilà, il faut que il faut que
collectivement,
sans que ça passe par des conventions
citoyennes, enfin des trucs complètement
démagogiques de mon point de vue, il
faut il faut qu'on mette en place des
des modes opératoires pour s'accorder
sur quelques grandes stratégies et
ensuite s'y tenir.
Petite parenthèse, ta boîte, elle vaut
combien ?
Ma boîte, elle vaut moins cher
aujourd'hui qu'hier euh
à cause de la fiscalisation.
Non mais non, parce que ma boîte ma
boîte elle intervient dans l'industrie,
elle intervient dans le bâtiment. Euh
bah elle est complètement tributaire de
marchés qui sont molaçons en ce moment.
Combien elle valait ta boîte ? B
à son po de forme elle valait elle
valait 5 ou 600 millions. Si elle en
vaut 300 aujourd'hui euh c'est le bout
du monde he
brut ouou net.
Brut ou net.
Tu as vu la l'interview de de la
ministre des finances australiennes ?
C'est quand même parenthèse fermée.
La PPE3 c'est un décret
Ouais.
Un décret à 300 milliards. Il y a
combien de zéro à 1 milliard ? 6
Oh non, tu [__] là je te jure je te
tapais.
Ouais mais ça ça dépasse l'entendement.
Et donc 300
300 milliards par décret.
Ouais
sur les questions démocratiques.
Ça veut dire que notre parlement est
devenu totalement inutile parce que ils
connaissent pas les dossiers ou quoi que
ce soit. Et Macron a décidé, du moins le
premier ministre a décidé de passer
outre 300 milliards.
Ouais. Alors, je dirais pas que le
Parlement est devenu inutile. D'abord,
je je distingue bien le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale.
À l'instant où on se parle, le Sénat est
quand même beaucoup plus stable,
beaucoup plus profond euh et euh capable
de dégager des consensus. L'Assemblée,
pour toutes les raisons que l'on sait,
suite à la dissolution, 14 groupes
parlementaires, ça n'était jamais
arrivé. Une pression
qui augmente tous les jours à l'approche
de l'élection présidentielle,
c'est ingérable. C'est absolument
ingérable. Donc on l'a bien vu parce que
la PPE, elle a été examinée au
Parlement. Ça a été un pugil. Un
pugilat. Et c'est ça renvoie à ce que je
te disais tout à l'heure dans cette
configuration mais peut-être aussi lié à
ce que j'ai dit de vachard sur le le
personnel politique. Euh
on pouvait pas aboutir. Alors qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait faire ? fallait attendre
la présidentielle puis une législative
qui immanquablement suivra la
présidentielle, c'est-à-dire reprendre
18 mois dans les genenscives ou prendre
ce risque y compris euh juridique hein
de de passer par euh par un décret. Bon
euh on verra on verra la suite des
événements, mais euh il y avait urgence
quand même à décider. D'après ce que je
peux voir autour de l'internet, on en
discute. Tu vois, Internet c'est devenu
une vraie agora où les gens peuvent
encore se rassembler pour discuter.
Paraît-il que la PPE3 ça va faire
exploser nos factures d'électricité ?
Euh,
il y a une grande inconnue dans ces
PPE3, c'est queelle nous donne pas les
prix ne serait-ce que les prix cibles.
Bon,
comment tu veux avoir une boîte si tu as
pas le une perspective de prix ? Alors,
tu as les tu as les hyper
électrointensifs
qui qui
contractent avec EDF en l'occurrence sur
sur du long terme et les choses se sont
accélérées parce qu'à un moment donné
c'était panique à bord avec en
particulier la la disparition de la
fameuse arène au 1er janvier 2026. Bon
euh Arcelor, Aluminium d'un kerkque,
March Kagilia qui va s'implanter à Fre
surmer. C'est beaucoup dans la
métallurgie à ce stade.
Saint-Gobin peut-être. Non,
Saint-Gobin, pas ma connaissance encore.
Enfin, c'est pas exactement le même
contrat, je crois. Euh, ont réussi à à
se sécuriser sur un prix qui est
confidentiel, mais on le connaît peu au
prou, donc je le donnerai pas. Qui qui
le d'évidence leur paraît compétitif.
Alors, c'est pas le prix de du gaz de
chiste américain sur le continent
américain. Mais enfin, ça reste
d'évidence compétitive sans quoi il
n'engagerait pas des investissements
aussi colossaux que que ce qu'ils font.
Le vrai sujet, il va à mon avis pas être
tellement pour ces hyper électroensifs,
il va être pour toutes les entreprises
qui sont immédiatement en dessous et qui
ne pourront pas signer des contrats de
même nature ou les plus de les plus
petites ou les toutes petites boîtes qui
elles vont être quand même soumises à
des prix de marché. Euh et donc euh
c'est une grosse inconnue et c'est vrai
que quand tu as dans tes dans tes prix
de revient industriel
euh un poids de d'un poid de l'énergie
de 10 15 %ah oui si ça double c'est
fatal donc on n'est pas encore tiré
d'affaires.
Après, il y a il y a un vrai un vrai
point d'interrogation qui est de savoir
si la thèse de la décarbonation va
devenir aussi
déterminante pour les investissements
industriels. Voilà.
Je veux dire par là que euh
s'il y a pas à la fois en terme de
tarification et en terme de demande du
marché une exigence forte sur la
décarbonation
et que donc la compétition reste
totalement ouverte géographiquement et
en terme de d'énergie, là on a vraiment
du souci à se faire. Euh moi je pense
qu'on a on a encore en Europe et en
France des des airments sur ce sujet-là.
Tout le monde dit il faut décarboner, il
faut décarboner, il faut décarboner. Il
y en a pas beaucoup qui sont prêts à
payer le coût de la décarbonation. Donc
là aussi, il y a de l'urgence à ce qu'on
clarifie les choses.
Trump est très agressif, Poutine est
très agressif, Sijingping est très
agressif, les Indiens sont très
agressifs, l'Amérique du Sud est très
agressive. Nous, on est au milieu, on
est censé être le vieux continent qui a
tout subi, qui a tout compris, qui s'est
positionné. Hm.
Quand tu dis qu'il y a des airements au
niveau tarif
h
que euh il faut décarboner, il faut
sauver les bébés f, il faut sauver la
planète et que on exporte notre
pollution ailleurs, que les Chinois ont
une production électrique qui explose
par tous les moyens, une consommation de
charbon qui explose aussi, que les
Allemands aussi ont des des coûts
énergétiques
avec des ressources derrière. Nous, la
France, il nous reste un peu le
nucléaire.
nos petites PME, nos boulangers, nos
artisans,
si ils se prennent un doublement de leur
facture électrique,
derrière, tu as des salariés qui vont
aussi euh
morfler.
Ouais.
Et il y a aussi des factures de
particulier qui vont morfler aussi. Oui.
Et le coût de production sur la bouffe,
sur tout un tas de trucs, ça va exploser
à à très court terme.
C'est une sacrée menace ça.
Quand est-ce que le MDF il va commencer
à à manifester ?
Ah non mais on
avec tu sais avec des pancartes là
le le à vrai dire le le MDEF manifeste
tous les jours.
Il se voit pas trop
après. Oui mais
tu comprends la boutade ?
Ouais. Moi je comprends bien
parce que si les patrons calanchent, les
salariés vont calancher aussi et si les
salariés, les patrons calanchent, le PIB
calanche, notre dette explose.
Et j'ajoute que dans l'état pitoyable de
nos finances publiques, on est infoutu
dans une avant de mettre en place le
temps qu'il faudrait un bouclier
tarifaire pour atténuer les effets d'une
nouvelle crise énergétique. Donc on est
le dos au mur, j'en suis
le dos au mur en short, sans bob, en
bretelle à poil. Ouais, enfin tous les
goûts sont de la nature. Euh mais euh
Non, je je partage ce que tu dis. Euh
d'où ma remarque sur le fait que la PPE
ne nous dit rien des des prix auxquels
l'électricité va sortir par profil de
consommateur. Les ménages des
entreprises. Typiquement, les Allemands
ont fait des choix qui privilégient si
on peut dire les entreprises. Donc par
voie de conséquence au détriment des
ménages sur le prix de l'énergie. Mais
euh
ça reste ambigu en France.
Tu commences la grève de la fin euh
quand ? On pas au programme. Euh
tu comprends ma blague ? Oui oui oui
mais pour est-ce que le Mevre de
pression à Sébastien le Cornu ?
Euh
alors il y a différentes sensibilités ou
lecture. Euh
je t'écoute.
Ouais. Il y a bon nombre de gens qui
disent "Il y en a marre que le MEDF nous
mette sous pression à ce point-là." Qui
ces gens ?
Alors c'est plutôt du côté des
politiques
ou mais [rires] on s'en fout.
Nous on fait le pays.
Ouais.
Alors on les met on les met quand même
sous pression.
Comment ?
Parce qu'on se bat pied à pied. Je te
donne un exemple. Euh il était prévu, ça
a été voté que de nouveau les
allègements de charge dont on peut dire
ce qu'on veut. Je suis prêt à en
débattre enfin qui sont déterminants en
terme de compétitivité. Je te coupe
tu quand tu dis allègement de charge, tu
dis allègement de cotisation.
Ouais, allégègement de cotisation. Je
crois avoir affaire à Sophie Binel qui
m'avait repris sèchement à la fête de
l'humanité par
Sophie Binel,
mon ami de la CGT. Ah
euh
ah oui, je vois je vois
parce que je me suis produit à deux
reprises à la fête de l'humanité, ce qui
est un exercice intéressant, pas autant
qu'aujourd'hui mais quand même. Et euh
vilain ou
et donc Sophie Binet,
tu commences, tu commences, tu sais ce
que tu vas avoir, hein.
Je je cr pire. Non, mais euh Sophie
Binet m'avait repris précisément
là-dessus parce que je parlais de charge
sociale, mais dit non, ce sont des
cotisations.
Moi, je je suis pas dans la théologie
donc disons que ce sont des cotisations.
Quoi qu'il en soit, il était prévu que
pour 2026,
de nouveau, il y a un coup de rabot sur
les les allègements de cotisation. On
parlait pas de l'épaisseur du trait, on
parlait de de près de 4 milliards
d'euros. Bon 4 milliards d'euros de mois
pour financer les entreprises, augmenter
les salaires, défendre l'emploi ou créer
des emplois. Bon, on a fait un travail
de combat rapproché et finalement on a
on a très significativement
abattu le le la douloureuse, si on peut
parler ainsi. Bon, sur la fiscalité du
patrimoine, on était parti dans des
délires. Dans des délires. Alors, moi,
je je je reconnaît que j'ai pris une
leçon parce que en matière de en matière
d'intoxication,
la taxe Zucman c'est un modèle du genre.
Modèle du genre. Enfin, moi je suis très
intéressé de d'entendre que la France
est à droite. Très bien. Je sais pas si
elle est à droite partout parce que sauf
erreur de ma part, y compris dans
l'électorat LR, la taxe Zucman était
populaire à 62 %.
Ça en dit long sur la compréhension de
l'économie par beaucoup de nos
concitoyens.
C'est quoi la moyenne d'âge chez les LR
?
Elle est elle est supérieure à à 60 ans.
Ouais. Bah oui, mais on pourrait dire
précisément, ils ont une maturité, ils
ont ils ont une expérience.
C'est quoi c'est quoi la moyenne d'âge
de de du téléspectateur de France
Télévision ? Il aime
Idam. Mais oui, mais non, mais c'est
c'est insultant pour les anciens ce que
tu dis là. Je me sens je me sens
directement visé.
Non mais toi tu es vieux mais ça va, tu
es un patron donc on peut s'en on peut
s'en plein la fouille. Mais tu parlais
d'intoxication,
c'est peut-être ça aussi. Non,
je comprends pas ce que tu veux dire.
Ceux qui regardent France Télévision, il
y a eu 25 passages de taxe duman, ils
croient ce qui se passe à la télé. Non.
Ouais, mais c'est alors précisément
c'est ce que je veux dire quoi. Tu tu tu
balances un truc qui est essentiellement
faux. Essentiellement faux. tu pilon euh
tu te pars d'une supposée euh légitimité
académique et alors ça impressionne. Bon
euh bilan des courses, on a dû mener sur
ce sujet quand même central de la
fiscalité des patrimoines un combat
défensif
défensif et on a essentiellement réussi
à parer le coup. Je rappelle quand même
que il était question alors la taxmane,
j'en parle même pas ça c'était
l'effondrement l'effondrement de
l'économie française signé garanti à
court terme. Bien on a échappé à ça mais
les uns et les autres je parle de nos
interlocuteurs politiques, ceux qui
discutent avec nous ont dit "Regardez,
on vous a permis d'échapper au pire. Il
n'empêche qu'ils avaient dans leur dans
leur carton des dispositifs qui semblent
être aussi douloureux ou débiles pour
dire les choses était quand même très
pénalisant. Moi, c'est mon vieux fond
marxiste euh qui qui qui est avéré hein.
Euh il faut
marxiste liste. Non.
Oui. Pas trotquiste. Euh
ouais. Euh non, enfin sauf erreur euh
notre pays a besoin de croissance, a
besoin de générer de la richesse. La
première préoccupation des Français,
c'est le pouvoir d'achat. Donc si tu
tapes euh sur le travail euh en
suspendant les réformes des retraites,
en ne t'intéressant pas à ce sujet
épouvantable qui est le sous-emploi des
jeunes et
et si par ailleurs tu dissuades ou tu
pénalises l'investissement, tu n'as ni
le travail ni le capital. Et donc tout
ce qui était prévu sur la taxation des
patrimoines, c'était le meilleur moyen
de faire partir les capitaux ou en tout
cas de faire en sorte que les gens qui
on en France ne le consacrent pas à
l'entreprise. Et là, on a mené un combat
euh un combat très technique euh
quotidien pour à la fin de mesures qui
soient réellement pénalisante pour le
capital. Mais enfin, c'est c'est
terrible de devoir mener des combats
défensifs alors qu'en ce moment, au
regard de tout ce qu'on a évoqué de la
compétition internationale, mais des
opportunités aussi qui existent, on
devrait mener des combats offensifs.
Je reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur cette étrange
loi, climat et résilience. Nous, on a
fait chiffrer que pour tenir la
trajectoire de décarbonation
des entreprises françaises, il faudrait
qu'elles investissent chaque année 30
milliards d'euros de plus. au BAM 30 à
40 milliards. Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça
veut dire qu'il faudra que
l'investissement des entreprises
augmente de 10 à 12 % par an. Quelle est
la réalité des chiffres ? La réalité des
chiffres, c'est que les entreprises
françaises au mieux maintiennent leur
volume d'investissement. Autant dire que
on se berce d'illusion ou on raconte des
salades en disant qu'on va atteindre
notre objectif de décarbonation et tout
est à l'avenant. Comment est-ce qu'on va
payer notre digitalisation ? Comment
est-ce qu'on va payer l'implémentation
nécessaire de l'intelligence
artificielle ? Donc à un moment donné
et on va le faire de manière chaque jour
un peu plus tonitruante, nous on va dire
attendez
arrêtez de parler pour ne rien dire.
Soit on prend collectivement le parti du
déclassement de la décroissance et de
l'appauvrissement acte, mais il faut que
ce soit dit. Soit on veut rester dans le
jeu et les entreprises ont un rôle
déterminant de ce point de vue et
donnons-nous les moyens de nos
ambitions. Donc il faut bosser plus.
Voilà, ça peut ne pas plaire. Enfin, moi
je suis convaincu que nos concitoyens
sont quand même pas totalement d puis
savent qu'à un moment donné, s'ils
veulent du pouvoir d'achat, il va
falloir qu'il bosse plus et libérons les
énergies pour qu'il y ait de
l'investissement parce qu'il y a cette
épargne en France.
Ouh là, attends, tu parles ce qui traîne
dans les couloirs du Sénat, taxé 10 % du
patrimoine brut de tous les Français.
Non.
Ah d'accord, on reviendra dessus.
Non, mais tu une ép disponible. Enfin,
elle est utilisée. C'était par l'argent
qui dort. Ça n'existe pas. J'ouvre une
parenthèse. Si tu me dis Patrick, OK,
c'est Patrick qui me parle, il me dit
"Bon, tu as de l'épargne, je vais te le
reuter pour faire de l'investissement
parce que j'ai un prisme de lecture
performant. J'ai fait mes preuves. Tu
comprends ? Même ma boîte si elle a pris
des coups de pieds dans le dans le
popotin, elle pèse quand même 300
millions quand même. Bon, tu fais un peu
moins crétin que le l'autre qui sait pas
calculer une TVA.
Attends, attends, tu as compris ? Donc
si j'ai un gouvernement
Ouais. qui me dit "Bon, on va rerouter
l'épargne des Français."
Mais moi, je me dis, ils sont même pas
capables de faire un budget. L'autre, il
sait même pas anticiper une TVA, une
provision de TVA. Les Français, ils vont
jamais vouloir qu'on touche à leur
épargne pour reuter alors qu'on a on a
des capitaines borgn
qui naviguent à vue selon le sens
électoral. Mais
non.
Est-ce que tu comprends le le la
défiance ? Je je donne un exemple.
Alors, c'est pas dans la tech euh c'est
dans le logement. On a eu pendant 6 ans,
pour ne pas dire 7 ans, un déni total
sur le logement. Il fallait pas mettre
d'argent dans le logement parce que
supposément c'était un productif. On est
passé à côté d'un enjeu colossal. Alors,
un enjeu économique pour commencer
démographique,
mais surtout un enjeu en terme de
pouvoir d'achat, en terme de mobilité
sociale. Enfin, je sais pas si tu as ça
en tête. Tu as 80 % des occupants de
logements sociaux dont certains sont au
chômage qui renoncent à une opportunité
professionnelle induisant à déménagement
parce que ils ont peur de pas pouvoir se
reloger à proximité de de l'emploi
qu'ils auront trouvé. En tout cas, se
loger à des abordables. Mais ils ont
infiniment raison. Donc de A à Z, ce
problème est absurde. Plus des problèmes
de de de vie en société que ça cause.
Pris la vanne sur la démographie. Oui,
le plus gros contraceptif en France,
c'est le prix du logement et le fait que
tu peux pas te loger.
Incroyable l'étude qui a été publiée il
y a un mois et demi. Incroyable. Moi, je
fais un très très gros focus sur la la
jeunesse, mais que l'année où on suspend
des réformes des retraite qui était
quand même
par trancière, si on peut dire ça comme
ça, puisque malgré tout, il y aurait eu
des déficits.
La même année, on a un déficit
démographique naturel et on prend acte
du fait que comme il y a pas assez de
logement alors que le l'envie d'enfant
finalement reste assez forte, 2,1 enfant
comme par hasard, exactement le taux de
remplacement,
ça baissé là.
Non, pas l'envie d'enfant. Ah oui,
le nombre d'enfants. On est descendu à
158 et on descend à une vitesse
phénoménale. Donc tout ça est un tissu
d'incohérence. Un tissu d'incohérence.
Alors à nouveau, moi je prétends pas
voir la science infuse. Ça se saurait,
ça se verrait mais ça ser pas dans le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance.
Patron tu es patron. Ta boîte elle pèse
un minimum.
ter un patron de terra est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est pas le moment un petit
peu d'aller casser des
Alors d'autant plus d'autant plus que
la confiance que place dans que place
nos concitoyens dans les entreprises n'a
jamais été aussi élevée c'est incroyable
et à vrai dire là où on ne fait que
parler de souffrance au travail
de mal-être de ceci de cela, le le la
côte de satisfaction des salariés et
pour le leurs entreprises restent
incroyablement élevé.
Quoi ta source ?
Bah il y a des études, il une étude de
l'Institut Montagne qui a été publié,
c'est c'est Martinau qui a publié ça il
y a 6 mois. 77 % des salariés se disent
satisfaits au travail. Alors, il y a
deux lectures. On peut dire "Ah bah oui,
ça veut quand même bien dire qu'il y en
a 23 % qui sont insatisfaits, tact." Je
suis bien curieux de savoir les
résultats qu'on aurait dans la fonction
publique qui nous donne matin, midi et
soir euh des leçons de vertu et de bon
management. Je pense que les résultats
seraient calamiteux, en tout cas
nettement moins bon. Mais donc moi ma
responsabilité, une de mes
responsabilités c'est euh c'est c'est de
porter ce message et de mobiliser les
2400 chefs d'entreprise adhérents du MF
pour leur dire "Arrêtez de raser les
murs, arrêtez de vous autoflageler,
arrêtez de faire un complexe de
persécution sans fanfaronner et en
restant à notre place parce qu'on n'est
pas des élus politiques. Il faut qu'on
assume tous ces chiffres et il faut
qu'on apporte de la rationalité dans le
débat public sans qu on va encore partir
dans des dans des délires sans fin et le
pays va s'enfoncer. Et alors nous on
n'est pas à nouveau on n'est pas là pour
faire de la politique au sens strict du
terme. Enfin notre intérêt c'est aussi
que le pays fonctionne.
Bon tu as mis un petit tacle à Sophie
Binet c'est ça la fête de Lar. Je me
fais l'avocat du diable.
les dividendes des grosses boîtes.
Ouais,
ça ça ça arrose un peu. Non,
mais
tu m'obliges à reprendre ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure. C'est pas illogique.
Enfin, tu as une tu as plus de la moitié
du capital des sociétés du CAC 40 en
moyenne qui est détenu par des
étrangers. Bon, là-dedans, il y a des
francophiles, certainement, c'est
peut-être pas la majorité de l'espèce.
de là à leur demander de ne pas prélever
de dividende euh au titre d'un
patriotisme français, on peut tenter le
coup hein, je suis pas sûr du résultat.
Enfin, je suis à peu près sûr du
résultat. Il serait probablement
malheureusement pas très positif. Euh
premier point. 2e point, ça aussi ça
fait partie de l'inculture économique de
notre pays. Tu mets pas d'argent dans
une boîte si tu as pas un rendement. Bon
al moi je me distribue pas de dividende
donc je pas le pas le meilleur exemple.
Tu gagnes combien ? Je gagne, tu me
croiras pas mais je sais le prouver, je
gagne 250000 € brut par an. Donc euh
donc après imp
alors un pot à pot sur le revenu
uniquement hein, ça doit faire du 160.
Euh voilà, je donc je je gagne en
salaire brut, je gagne 10 fois le
salaire médite. Voilà pour une boîte de
d'un milliard d'euros de chif
d'affaires, 3000 salariés. Mais après,
c'est des choix personnels et je suis je
suis propriétaire de la boîte, donc
c'est moi qui décide de ma rémunération.
Voilà. Donc je considère que je vis très
convenablement comme ça. Ce qui me vaut
de préciser que je suis bénévole au
MEDF. Faut aimer, hein. Faut aimer. Euh
mais c'est passionnant. J'aime euh
monter tes salaires dans ta boîte là.
cette année. Oui.
Oui. Enfin là là sur 2026, c'est en
cours de négociation donc je reste
discret.
Sur
2025 on a été on a été très prudent très
prudent. On a augmenté entre le général
et l'individuel de 1,2 %.
Tu as fait des primes ?
Euh bah les primes, c'est les primes de
d'objectif de performance.
Alors certains les ont touchés, d'autres
pas.
Revenons à notre président de la
République solaire et son premier
ministre gigantesque.
On commence par lequel ?
Vas-y, je te donne je te donne d'abord.
Je n'ends pas le
président solaire.
Bon, solaire, je sais pas trop ce que ça
veut dire solaire. Bah,
il est lumineux. Il est écoute, je pense
qu'il a il a de formidables intuitions.
Donc on commence par le président de la
République. Donc on va on va pas
commencer par le président de la
République. Notre premier ministre
Sébastien Lecnu qui
se prend pour le plan Mesmer.
Mesmer les deux premières.
Tu peux pas tu peux pas me faire
endosser ces ces commentaires. Donc je
dis non, je ne partage pas.
C'est une boutade.
Ouais.
Le plan Mesmer, il nous a pendu combien
de gigw les deux premières années ?
Euh,
il a dû en pondre sur les deux premières
années, il a dû en pondre,
alors je je raisonne en terw 150 ou 160
terw
en gw ça fait
bah ça fait 1000 fois 1000 fois plus en
gw
quand tu vois notre premier ministre
gigantesque
dire que la PPE3 c'est le plan mesmè et
que c'est on va faire six réacteurs et
que c'est le c'est le nouveau plan
Mesmer. Tu as pas l'impression que il
fait un peu petit bras par rapport à
Mesmer et qu'il fait des grandes
annonces parce que les gens ils vont pas
se pencher sur ce qu'avait sorti Mesmer,
ce qui avait sorti Zamenber, ce qu'avait
sorti le président le le général de
Gaulle.
Tu as pas l'impression que c'est petit
bras et que c'est pas français d'être
petit bras ?
Non. Alors à sa décharge, il y a
C'est une blague électrique ça, non ?
Ouais. Ouais.
Euh
il y a une énorme inconnue qui est de
savoir quelle sera la consommation
d'électricité.
Euh et on était parti RT enfin tout le
monde il y a une forme de consensus sur
une augmentation considérable de la
consommation de d'électricité liée au
transport, lié au logement, lié à
l'industrie. La réalité c'est que à ce
jour la consommation d'électricité
n'augmente pas. Alors, elle augmente pas
alors que il y a il y a quand même de
plus en plus de véhicules électriques et
qu' a une électrification relative et et
très très lente du bâtiment. Ça veut
dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que l'activité
d'abord qu'on a tous fait, tant mieux
d'une certaine manière des efforts de
frugalité.
Ça ça s'appelle pas des efforts de
frugalité, c'està dire se serrer la
ceinture.
Non non non non, je non non.
Des croissances frugales, tu es en train
de me dire
non non mais comportementalement non
mais même dans les boîtes, on fait un
peu plus attention. Il y a des processus
de fabrication qui ont été optimisés.
Non, il y a quand même un peu d'effet de
frugalité qui est pas sacrificiel. Euh
mais ça veut surtout dire que l'activité
est très molle, très très molle. Euh
donc c'est pas une bonne explication.
Pour autant, on ne sait pas comment va
évoluer la consommation d'électricité.
Donc si quand le plan Mesmer a été
lancé, euh les circonstances étaient pas
tout à fait les mêmes et euh on savait
parce qu'on avait pris plein la tête
avec le premier choc pétrolier, mais
c'était le premier à ce moment-là. avant
le second qui est arrivé en 79 euh on on
on savait queon allait droit dans le mur
si on ne s'émancipait pas en bonne part
de la dépendance au aux hydrocarbures
euh notamment du Moyen-Orient.
Deuxème point, il y avait de l'argent
dans les caisses,
ce qui n'est évidemment plus du tout le
cas.
Là on a des dettes,
pardon.
Là on a des dettes.
B on a des dettes à plus savoir qu'en
faire. Enfin, c'est c'est donc ça limite
le champ des possibles. Et euh 3è point
euh je
c'est un commentaire aigre doux euh on
était on était libre de nos mouvements
par rapport à l'Union européenne. Voilà.
Euh donc et et enfin et enfin et enfin
il y avait une majorité parlementaire.
Donc tout ça mis bout à bout fait que à
la fois en terme de visibilité et de
capacité d'exécution, les circonstances
étaient pas du tout les mêmes. Bon, le
premier ministre mais il il a il est
confronté à toutes les raisons inverses
inverses.
possibilité de voter une PPE au
Parlement, des contraintes européennes
qui à certains égards sont inopportunes,
euh plus d'argent public
et euh et pas de visibilité sur ce que
sera la consommation demain. Donc
et des taux qui augmentent
et des taux qui augmentent enfin non
parce que les taux en 73 avaient avaient
flombré hein. Les taux en 73 il devaient
être à 15 ou 16 %.
On avait combien de dettes à l'époque ?
Bon, à l'époque, on devait avoir euh en
en proportion du PB, on devait être à 37
%.
Aujourd'hui, on est à
bah on va on est on a passé les 118 % et
on va arriver à 120 %. Euh
même si les taux sont bas, on paye plus.
Bah, les taux sont bas, ils sont pas si
bas que ça. Ils sont pas si bas que ça
parce que quand on voit qu' a 10 ans
d'empreinte à quoi 4 et5 %, ça fait des
taux réels qui sont quand même vachement
élevés, hein.
Je vois que tu es à l'aise avec les
chiffres.
Les intérêts de la dette française par
jour, c'est combien
par jour ? Écoute, ça va être cette
année, ça va être 70 milliards. Donc je
te laisse diviser par faut les annéon en
jour ouvré en plus. Donc euh
ça doit faire au moins 500 millions par
jour.
On consomme combien de baril de pétrole
en France par jour pour faire
fonctionner nos boîtes ?
pour faire fonctionner les Alors,
je te laisse convertir euh euh en en
milliard d'euros.
Euh est-ce que tu veux
écoute, on apporte on apporte de l'ordre
de 50 milliards d'euros par an en gaz et
en pétrole. Bon, 50 pris en tendance
actuelle, c'est 50.
Mais je sais pas, sincèrement, je sais
pas dire ce qui ce qui est consommé par
les ménages, qui est consommé par les
entreprises,
la France en totalité.
boî les boîtes et les ménages.
Alors euh tuas pas l'impression que les
Je te sauve les invoir
les intérêts de la dette qu'on paye tous
les jours
ou Ouais.
C'est supérieur
à
à notre déficit énergétique.
Ah exactement.
Bien sûr,
bien sûr. Mais je vois pas le le rapport
si tu peux.
D'accord. Alors, je vais je vais je vais
faire je vais faire une petite blague.
Un chef d'entreprise qui fait de la
cavalerie, il termine où ?
Ah bah, il termine à poil pour
commencer.
Ouais. Et ensuite, il termine derrière
les barreau.
Mais si c'est du pénal, il finit
derrière les barreaux.
Tu sais où je veux en venir là ? Le
budget, est-ce que tu as l'impression
que nos politiques
sont en train de faire de la cavalerie
pour couvrir leur inconséquences
intellectuelles ou leur inconséquence de
terme de prise ?
tout à l'heure en disant que enfonce le
clou.
Non, mais il y a il y a plus
suffisamment de la responsabilité pour
les politiques, ça devrait être l'échec
électoral. Enfin bon, et il y a plus
suffisamment de responsabilité
politique. Moi je trouve indécent
indécent qu' a eu des erreurs
à la fois sur le plan stratégique et en
terme de gestion aussi lourde que celle
que l'on constate, mais c'est vrai au
niveau européen et que euh finalement,
mais ça c'est les électeurs au bout du
compte qui en décident. Euh il y a il y
a pas de sanction. Il y a pas de
sanction. Voilà. Ben on s'est gourré sur
telle telle législation. Bah oui, ben
c'est pas de ma faute. Euh et c'est vrai
que les les sanctions euh pour les
agents économiques, parce que c'est vrai
les ménages aussi hein, euh
il y a d'ailleurs un nombre de de
ménages qui sont en commission de
surendettement ou en situation de
surendettement qui est en train
d'augmenter significativement. Et à un
moment donné, est interdit de checker
pour ceux qui utilisent encore les
chèqus. Euh et idem ild pour les les
entrepreneurs. Donc il y a deux points
de mesure et je veux dire franchement
euh je pense que c'est l'explication
directe du discrédit du discrédit du
politique aux yeux de l'opinion et que
que je trouve très grave. Je pourrais me
dire formidable. Les entreprises ont une
côte de popularité record et les
politiques ont une côte les politiques
nationaux ont une côte de popularité
déplorable. On est les rois du pétrole.
Non. D'abord, je pense que ça pose un
méga problème démocratique et je crains
qu'on le vérifie assez rapidement.
Sous quelle forme ?
Bah, ça veut dire qu'il va il va y avoir
par exaspération, par défaut, par
déposité
des votes euh qui pour certains ne me
semblent pas pouvoir garantir l'avenir
du pays.
Euh voilà, c'est bien dit, non ?
Et et donc mais la deuxième conséquence
de de cette distorsion de code de
confiance, c'est qu'à partir de là, on
demande tout et le contraire de tout aux
entreprises. Et quand on regarde au fil
des ans le nombre de responsabilités
qu'on a fait supporter aux entreprises
et qu'elles supportent sur le plan
sociétal, sur le plan environnemental,
bon on l'assume. Bon, après, après faut
jamais perdre de vue que si on gagne pas
d'argent euh c'est un exercice d'assez
court terme, hein. Donc ne perdons pas
de vue le le le préalable. Il faut que
les entreprises gagnent de l'argent.
Mais au rythme vont les choses, c'est
déjà un peu le cas. On va nous demander
de former tout le monde, d'assurer la
sécurité. Tout ça n'est pas imaginable.
N'est pas imaginable. D'abord parce que
c'est pas ce que prévoit la démocratie.
C'est pas ce pourquoi les entreprises
sont faites. Euh et euh et donc ça
créera une confusion incroyable. Et à
quoi servirait les politiques à partir
de là ? Donc c'est tout ça est très
malsin.
On parle un peu du budget là.
Oui.
Euh les entreprises, elles prennent
combien de milliards en plus cette année
dans la tête ?
Alors tout dépend par rapport à quoi.
Euh parce que la thèse du gouvernement,
je dirais c'est de bonne guerre. Il y a
99,9 % des entreprises qui vont pas
payer plus d'impôt. C'est pas tout à
fait exact
mais ça c'est par rapport à 2025. à part
que à part que il y avait des annonces
formelles officielles réitérées selon
lesquelles le la surtaxe d'impôts sur
les sociétés ça serait one shot 2025
nada. Bon, elle a été elle a été un peu
réduite en terme de de montant et de
nombre d'entreprises concernées, mais
elle est toujours là. Et je pense que
c'est terrible en terme de signal, mais
surtout en terme d'impact économique.
Euh, il avait été dit que enfin les la
baisse des impôts de production
reprendrait parce que c'est ça qui est
le plus disqualifiant pour notre
industrie en particulier. Nada, ben non,
on peut pas, on verra ça un peu plus
tard. Mais nous, à la limite, on peut
comprendre ces choses-là.
Mais ce qu'on comprend pas, c'est que en
regard
économies massives qui devraient être
faite et ça plaît pas mais on doit en
passer par notamment sur le social et
qui n'ont pas été faites. C'est même
pire que ça puisqu'on a reculé sur la
réforme des retraites. Donc quand tu
vois le le projet de loi de finance de
la sécurité sociale, non seulement il y
a pas eu d'économie mais il y a des
dépenses supplémentaires. Évidemment euh
les les gens vont pas me sauter au coup
dans la rue tout à l'heure, mais enfin
passer la franchise médicale de 1 € à 2
€ c'est quand même pas la mort du petit
cheval. surtout si on prévoit que les
gens les plus impéculieux et il en
existe
ne ne se voit pas appliquer cette
mesure. Il y a il y a toute une litanie
de choses qui étaient prévues qui n'ont
pas été faites et par votre conséquence
parce qu'il faut tenir un déficit
supposément de 5 % qui est déjà
monstrueux hein et bien l'État s'est
refait sur le projet de loi de finance
avec cette surtax IS avec le nouveau
report de la baisse de la CVE. Donc si
tu veux euh à un moment donné faut pas
s'étonner que il y a pas de dynamique
économique, que le marché de l'emploi
commence à se retourner, que le niveau
d'investissement ne soit pas celui qui
devrait être en dehors même de ce que
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure sur la
décarbonation et la digitalisation. Donc
euh on est en train on est en train de
de à la fois d'assoupir et d'asphhixer
le pays. Bon, à un moment donné, on va
être rattrapé par la patrouille. C'est
pas nécessairement c'est pas
nécessairement un accident de crédit
hein.
La patrouille c'est le FMI.
Non, c'est les c'est les performes. Moi
je La France reste riche. Je parlais de
l'épargne des Français tout à l'heure.
La France reste riche et notre État est
reconnu pour sa capacité à lever
l'impôt. Donc c'est formidable. Tout ça
est très rassurant pour nos créanciers
parce que nos créanciers nous font payer
de plus en plus cher le leur prêts. Je
rappelle que pour plus de la moitié, la
dette française est détenue par des
étrangers. Enfin, tout à l'heure on on
évoquait où j'évoquais les grosso modo
35 % de dettes sur PIB au début des
années 70, il y avait une autre
différence, c'est que la dette au 23
était détenue par des Français.
De la même manière qu'on parle de la
dette qui est importante de l'Italie,
même si l'Italie redresse
remarquablement son déficit budgétaire,
euh la dette italienne est détenue à 60
% par des domestiques, par des Italiens.
Donc si tu veux, on s'est mis dans une
situation de dépendance qui n'est plus
tenable. Qui n'est plus tenable. Donc il
faut il faut poser les vrais problèmes.
Cette situation de dépendance, c'est une
laisse avec un collier étrangleur.
Ouais.
Tu sais ce que ça veut dire ? Oui oui
oui oui, je vois très bien. Je vois très
bien. Mais
et donc et donc qui est-ce qui va nous
faire chanter ?
Qui est-ce qui va nous mettre des coups
de sonnette ?
Euh bah tu vasir tu tu as déjà un
phénomène, c'est un phénomène de de
perte de puissance, de perte d'influence
et de moindre attractivité de la France.
Enfin dans les débats actuels au sein de
l'Union européenne, c'est flagrant. Moi,
je on n'est pas allé au bout du propos
tout à l'heure, mais je pense que Macron
a une vision assez assez juste de ce que
devrait faire l'Europe, à part que la
voix de la France d'évidence porte moins
qu'elle portait une époque et qu'elle
devrait porter. Donc c'est c'est déjà un
des contre-coups de cette situation
financière. Mais par ailleurs euh on
nous prête de plus en plus cher. Euh le
l'attractivité de la France ne
s'effondre pas mais elle s'éti
je sais pas dire à quel rythme ça peut
être ça peut être très très douloureux
mais donc ça peut être très progressif
ou très brutal. Moi je pense que ça va
être progressif mais assez rapide. Je
sais pas si je suis clair.
Progressif mais assez rapide.
C'estàd qu'on va accélérer on va
accélérer notre décrochage. Alors notre
décrochage, on se gargarise en disant
"Ouais mais on a quand même eu de la
croissance l'année dernière." Moi,
j'avoue que mon pronostic n'était pas
celui-là. On pensait qu'on ferait du 05
06 maximum. On a fait du 0,9. Très bien.
Pour
pour combien de milliards de dettes en
plus ?
Ah bah c'est intégralement financé à
crédit. C'est-à-dire
bah c'est-à-dire sur le sur le 3e et sur
le 4e trimestre, sur chacun des des deux
derniers trimestres, mais c'était grosso
modo vrai, sur les deux premiers
trimestres de 2025, la dette augmenté de
70 milliards d'euros. C'est-à-dire que
la dette a augmenté plus vite si tu
raisonnes en valeur absolue, que le le
PIB. Donc on finance tout ça avec.
Donc le 0.9
de croissance, ça
il est il est c'est c'est
70 milliards d'euros si je te suis bien.
Bah 0.9
non. Euh non, tu as un PIB qui est 2900
milliards. Donc on a une croissance sur
l'ensemble de l'année de l'ordre mettons
de de 20 de 250 milliards et en face tu
as une dette qui a augmenté de près de
300 milliards.
Un chef d'entreprise s'il fait
ah bah ça dure pas longtemps.
Ouais
ouais.
Ça ça sent le sapin là non ?
Et tu parlais de de de décrochage ?
Ouais,
je sais que tu fais un peu d'autres
montagne.
Ouais,
comme monsieur Routeux
tu faisais peut-être.
Non, lui est plus marin mais
Ouais. Et puis
ouais. Quand tu commences à prendre de
la vitesse avec tes skis,
pour t'arrêter, après c'est compliqué.
Et puis pour regrimper la pente.
Voilà,
c'est ça qui est problématique. Quand
Attends, pour regrimper la pente, tu as
les Chinois,
tu as les Américains, énergie pas cher
et vas-y que je te protectionniste à
Donf
et que je militarise mon appareil fiscal
pour aller embêter les autres boîtes des
petits copains, que j'ai la NSA qui
s'amuse à surveiller les boîtes
françaises au-dessus de 20 millions
d'euros les contrats. Non, 250 millions
d'euros. 20 millions de roul contrat. La
NSA te regarde
une petite coloscopie qui va bien de la
NSA.
et je te vois rigoler.
Ouais.
Là la France elle est en en danger.
On voit on voit les partis politiques
complètement décrochés.
Y en a une poignée qui maîtrise les
dossiers qui ont pris réellement
conscience du problème.
Et il nous reste quoi ? Les patrons,
nous nos boîtes, nos salariés.
Ouais. Alors,
les médias ont pas l'air d'être
relativement
affutés sur ces sujets
ou de donnent pas correctement le signal
du réel danger.
Est-ce que tu as peur pour notre pays ?
Euh non.
Non.
Tu as pas peur parce que tes actifs ils
sont pas en euros, ils sont ailleurs ?
Non, moi je suis moi mon patrimoine il
est en France et l'activité de ma boîte
c'est 90 % en France. Donc
tu dors bien la nuit ?
J'ai la chance de bien dormir la nuit.
Alors, je sais pas comment je dois
l'interpréter, mais bon. Euh
quand tu regardes quand tu regardes les
enquêtes d'opinion, moi il y a une chose
qui me frappe beaucoup par exemple et
les les syndicats, ils sont dans le
rôlein, mais certains politiques qui de
mon point de vue sont moins dans leur
rôle me servent ça matin, midi soir.
Tuas encore 2/3 des Français qui sont
opposés à la réforme des retraites. Très
bien.
Tu regardes d'autres sondages, tu as à
peu près autant de Français qui
considèrent que les régimes sociaux vont
voler en éclat. Et quand tu regardes
plus finement encore, tu as doré avant
40 % des jeunes qui disent "Moi, je vais
pas m'emmerder à payer des cotisations
sociales ou des charges euh pour le jour
venu ne pas bénéficier en particulier
des retraites." Plus précisément encore,
quand tu regardes l'âge des
micro-entrepreneurs,
il y a 10 ans, c'était 20 % de jeunes,
maintenant c'est un/ers de jeunes.
Alors, il y a probablement différentes
explications, mais il y en a une qui est
avérée, c'est précisément celle-là,
c'est de dire
non non, je je suis pas le gogo qui va
payer des régimes sociaux par
répartition dont je ne serai pas
bénéficiaire le jour venu.
Qu'ils ont compris ce que c'était une
pyramide de Ponz.
Voilà, ils ont compris. Et alors, moi je
retire une
le système de retraite, c'est une
pyramide de Ponzi.
Oui, mais oui. Euh,
c'est quoi une pyramide de Ponzi ?
C'est c'est c'est-à-dire que tu tu
vends à ton tu fais avaler à ton voisin
euh que un un placement qui de toute
façon va rapporter de des des sommes
pharamineuses avec des taux pharamineux.
Puis comme c'est pas le cas, ben lui
revend ça encore à troisème. Puis à la
fin, tu as le gogo, le le type qui
récupère la patate chaude. La patate,
elle peut être très brûlante. Donc on
est on est sur ce scénario là. C'est
vrai. Mais là où je veux positiver,
c'est que quand je suis
on est en train de sacrifier notre
jeunesse.
Non, non, mais alors je je c'est là que
je voulais en venir. Euh moi quand je
fais état de tous ces sondages, je passe
pas ma vie sur le le nez sur les
sondages. Ça me ça me convain ça me
convaincitoyens
euh
profitent du système tant qu'il existe
mais savent très bien que ça un moment
ou un autre, il va falloir se retrousser
les manches. Et le vrai le vrai sujet
c'est de c'est d'avoir une offre
politique. Il faut que il faut que les
chefs d'entreprise contribuent à ce
débat et cetera, mais il faut une offre
politique, ça dépasse ma condition mais
je le dis quand même qui à la fois ne
soit pas punitive. Berérou a essayé hein
et finalement il était très maladroit
mais ce qu'il disait c'était la vérité
des prix hein. Mais si si tu te limites
à ça sans dire qu'il y a un projet
derrière et moi je pense qu'il peut y
avoir un projet qui soit à défaut d'être
enthousiasment en tout cas mobilisateur
là on va directement dans le mur. Mais
je je
moi je traîne mes guettres un peu
partout. Je pense qu'il y a une attente
une attente d'un projet qui soit pas
totalement fantasmé, qui soit pas
totalement irréaliste, mais quand même
qui redonne de la dignité, de l'envie et
des perspectives. Et j'en viens aux
jeunes.
On a en particulier pour moi, c'est le
sujet numéro 1. C'est le sujet numéro 1.
Très bien. Il faut s'occuper des seiors,
on s'en occupe. Faudra s'en occuper
mieux, on s'en occupera mieux. Parfait.
Euh mais tu as quand même euh
1400000 jeunes qui ne sont ni en emploi,
ni en formation, ni en étude.
Euh
personne n'en parle.
On reste et on veut absolument rester
dans un régime de
protection sociale par répartition. Très
bien. On a un taux de chômage chez ces
jeunes qui ont encore augmenté. Il est à
20 21,5 % d'oravant. On a 35 % des
jeunes qui sont en emploi. Les
Allemands, c'est 51 %. Euh les
Hollandais, c'est 75 %. J'ai pas compris
que ni l'Allemagne ni la Hollande était
des régimes fascistes. Bon, donc
peut-être
donc l'apprentissage. Alors, comme on
est très intelligent, on est en train de
détricoter à Baboui le succès
extraordinaire qu'enfin on avait eu sur
l'apprentissage. Je mets tous ces
chiffres bout à bout pour dire quoi ?
pour dire que si collectivement
on on se consacre à l'orientation, à la
formation de la jeunesse, à l'inclusion
et c'est des publics très différents
pour certains horriblement compliqués à
à traiter, je le dis positivement mais
quand même si on réussit à rejoindre le
taux d'emploi des jeunes qu'à
l'Allemagne, on a plus de déficit
sociaux mais personne n'en parle
et moi je ne me l'explique pas. Donc
moi, j'ai mis dans la nature un certain
nombre de propositions. Évidemment,
certains pos tapé dessus, non ?
Par certains t'es fait taper dessus.
Pourquoi ? Sur quelle mesure ? Qu'est-ce
qui a été mal accueilli ? Qu'est-ce que
tu as mal expliqué ? Pas souond
d'amorment parce que c'est peut-être
été, je l'ai peut-être je l'ai peut-être
proposé de manière un peu un peu
précipitée, ça n'enlève rien à ma
conviction. On a proposé en particulier
un contrat qui est en fait copiercollé
de l'apprentissage. Un copiercollé de
l'apprentissage c'estàd qu'en
contrepartie d'un engagement ferme et
contrôlé de l'entreprise à former des
jeunes qui par définition ne sont pas
formés puisqu'on parle de ceux qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi. Donc en
contrepartie de cet engagement avoir
dans un premier temps une rémunération
inférieure au SMIC. Alors là tout le
monde hur là là ils nous refont le coup
du contrat premier embauche. Oui, c'est
assez étonnant parce que il ne t'a pas
échappé que les apprentis sont payés
moins que le SMIC. Il y a un taux de
satisfaction des apprentis eux-mêmes, de
leurs familles, des entreprises et je
dirais de la collectivité qui est
extraordinaire. On a un taux de
placement à l'emploi des apprentis qui
est nettement supérieur 70 % au terme de
leur de leur parcours nettement
supérieur à celui des jeunes qui sont
dans les cursus classiques. Donc moi à
un moment donné je dis bon écoutez on
peut se on peut se balancer des des
insultes à la figure à longueur de
journée et cetera. Bon allez ok on ne
s'occupe pas des jeunes. On continue
comme ça. C'est parfait. Une bombe
retardement. Une bombe retardement. Et
comme je suis un peu provocateur, je dis
aux mêmes qui me disent "No, ouais, ton
truc c'est épouvantable." J'en dis "Mais
qu'est-ce que vous proposez d'autre ?"
Bah, j'attends.
Pour l'instant, j'ai rien vu.
Bon, je m'emporte là-dessus mais c'est
l'éléphant milieu de la pièce, quoi. On
a Et c'est ça aussi qui me rend
optimiste, c'estàd que si on si on
adresse ce sujet-là avec toute l'énergie
et tous les moyens qu'il faut, on règle
beaucoup de problèmes. On règle nos
problèmes de natalité. On règle nos
problèmes de compétences, on règle nos
problèmes de tension sur les
recrutements, on règle nos problèmes
d'équilibre des régimes sociaux, on
règle pas mal de problèmes de sécurité,
en tout cas d'ordre public, hein. Euh,
on règle les problèmes de natalité, on
règle les problèmes de logement. Enfin,
c'est c'est pour moi c'est une évidence.
Et ben non.
La période d'essai de 3 ans, c'est quoi
cette histoire ?
Mais c'est pas une période d'essai de 3
ans, c'est un CDI.
C'est un CDI euh
qui peut être interrompu sans motif.
Alors c'est dégueulasse, c'est
scandaleux.
Américaine.
Ouais. Alors ça existe en Allemagne, ça
existe en Italie, ça existe en Hollande.
Bon, mais je dis pas que c'est je dis
pas que c'est la bonne solution. Je dis
que ça fait partie des propositions
qu'on a qu'on a posé sur la table. Très
bien.
Il y a combien de jeunes qui sont en CDI
?
dans les 3 ans du début de leur carrière
professionnelle 10 %.
Bon
voilà donc on est rentré dans des pol de
faire de signer combien de CDD à la
suite ?
Bah, tu peux signer trois
euh sauf dans la fonction publique ou
alors là
20 30 bon de points de mesure là aussi
euh donc voilà, je pardon, je m'emballe
un peu sur ce sujet des jeunes mais ça
me choque en tant que citoyen, en tant
que père et grand-père pour pour être
tout à fait complet, ça me choque que il
y a cet angle mort de des politiques
publiques et qui qui débute très tôt
définitivement Parce que quand on voit
le Allez, je vais te mesurer. L'érosion
l'érosion de la place de la France dans
les classements internationaux teams
PISA et cetera.
Tu peux le reformuler d'une façon un peu
plus fleurrie, s'il te plaît ?
Euh
non, mais le déclassement, le
déclassement. Et là aussi quand on
signale ça, certaines corporations
considèrent que c'est une agression.
Ici, on nomme un chat un chat. C'est
quoi ? certaines corporations,
non mais certains enseignants ou
certaines organisations syndicales
d'enseignants, c'est pas du tout le
sujet. Enfin, moi je je suis pas
enseignant et on va dire j'ai j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour les enseignants
parce que j'irais pas quelle qu'on soit
la rémunération, on va dire hein,
j'irais pas enseigner dans les certains
quartiers prioritaires de la ville, mais
même dans des quartiers bourgeois où
maintenant il y a des gamins quand c'est
pas leurs parents qui ont des
comportements totalement insupportables.
Donc je me garde de stigmatiser les
enseignants. Il n'en meur pas moins que
quand on fait état de ce déclassement
quand même assez rapide et très
inquiétant de la France
ou sur la maîtrise des des du français
des mathématiques
chez les lycéens. Enfin, c'est tout ça
est très inquiétant quand même au même
moment où on sait qu'on est rentré dans
l'économie de la connaissance et où on
va avoir besoin de compétences très
pointu et sans se renouveler. Donc le
fait de ne même pas pouvoir dire ça sans
séance tenant de passer pour un
provocateur, je trouve ça dingue. Je
trouve ça dingue et je pense que
collectivement
avec les enseignants devrait se dire
comment on corrige tir ? Comment on
corrige tir ? Et ben tu vois ça aussi ça
me rend optimise parce qu'on a on arrivé
à un point tel que il va falloir que les
uns et les autres peut-être le médaf
lui-même on sort de nos postures et on
sort d'une forme de résignation de
fatalisme en disant bah ouais c'est
comme ça puis
viennent que pour Benah non
le fameux rebond du chat mort.
Voilà.
Bon on passe un peu à l'international.
Ouais,
parce que là on pourra en discuter
pendant des heures à des
Ouais, enfin tu vois je pardon, je je
bien vu les réactions mais finalement
beaucoup moins virulentes qu'on aurait
pu le craindre que que les propositions
des MDEF ont pu susciter. Je glisse au
passage qui est un sondage élable qui
qui est assez surprenant. Moi-même, j'en
suis agréablement surpris. selon lequel
49 % des jeunes considèrent que les
propositions qu'à titre exploratoire on
a mis sur la table sont recevables.
Ah,
faut désespérer de rien.
Tiens, tu parles de de mesurettes à
titre exploratoire, je te chambre un
peu. Et la surveillance algorithmique
dans les supermarchés,
ça c'est bien, c'est pas bien.
Euh
les fuites de données de nos boîtes ?
Non non mais ça c'est non c'est
Attends attends alors supermarché
la vidéos surveillance algorithmique qui
était que pour le Ju mais maintenant qui
est en train d'être expérimenté dans les
les supermarchés. Euh moi
philosophiquement en tant que citoyen,
je trouve que c'est pas bien.
Bon, les fuites de données nos boîte, on
se fait ouvrir à l'ouvreboîte, on se
fait euh proctoliser, euh fibroscoper,
euh
on se fait pour être pour employer un
mot un jargon que tout le monde connaît.
On se fait ouvrir de la tête au pied.
Ouais.
On fait quoi ? on continue à se faire
ouvrir quand on essaie de faire quelque
chose. Si je peux pas
le MDEF le MEDF, il en pense quoi ? Le
fait que nos données
se fassent exfiltré à gogo par peut-être
des puissances étrangères
en train de scanner l'intégralité de
notre population. Et on va dire qu'en
cas de guerre avec une petite
intelligence artificielle, le numéro de
téléphone portable de tout le monde, la
voix de tati, la voix de mamie, la voix
de papa, on dit "Oh là là, il y a une
centrale nucléaire qui crame, il faut
que tu dégages." On est en train de
créer des mouvements de panique, on est
en train d'ouvrir nos boîtes, on est en
train de d'avoir des arnaques. Comment
c'est quoi l'arnaque avec l'arnaque au
chef d'entreprise où tu mets une
perruque, tu te fais passer pour euh
et le MDEF, il tire la sonnette
d'alarme, il fait comment ?
Ouais. Alors bon, tu as plus
croise pas tes bras.
Ouais,
tu as plein de sujets dans le sujet. Euh
bon, d'abord nous on participe avec
l'ANC avec un certain nombre la
gendarmerie
ou
euh gendarmerie et cetera.
Ouais.
Oui. Oui. Euh à tout cet effort de
sensibilisation, bon on chemine. Euh
après, tu as tout ce qui est
réglementaire. Alors là, je reconnais
queon a des dilemmes parce que
DSA, DMA et cetera,
euh
il faut qu'on se protège mais il faut
pas que ça pénalise les acteurs
européens. Tu vois, le le fait que les
acteurs européens ne puissent pas
accéder aux données et traiter les
données, finalement ça nous disqualifie.
Donc partant d'une bonne attention à la
protection des données, il faut pas que
en terme de puissance de calcul, en
terme de technologie, on se pénalise
nous-même. Je sais pas si je suis clair.
Euh manifestement non. Euh et puis après
tu as tu as les outils eux-mêmes.
Donc nous on est très très en soutien de
par exemple l'implantation de data
center sur euh sur le territoire
européen et français. à part que à part
que les grands opérateurs les grands
opérateurs américains disons les choses
ont une puissance de feu financière
telle que il y a un risque non nul reste
prudent que il capte en réalité ses ses
capacités indispensables notamment à
l'intelligence artificielle. Donc on
retombe toujours sur le même sujet. Il
faut une stratégie, il faut des moyens
et des moyens financiers pour non
seulement protéger mais développer nos
acteurs
domestique.
Ça fait beaucoup de yakucon ça. Non mais
non
euh
enfin si euh on peut mettre ce dont je
doute un petit peu hein 300 milliards
sur la PPE y compris avec les réseaux
euh on doit bien pouvoir trouver bon
quand il y a le sommet de l'intelligence
artificielle il y a eu, si je me
souviens bien pour 108 milliards d'euros
d'annonces d'investissement dans les
data centers. Bon, c'est jamais que le
tiers de ce qu'on est, semble-t-il prêt
à mettre sur le l'énergie et d'ailleurs
les deux sujets convergent, hein, euh
énergie et notamment énergie, production
d'électricité et data centers. Euh donc
euh
le vrai problème, c'est que il faut que
ça se traite à l'échelle européenne. On
on sait plus nous lever de l'argent à ce
niveau-là. Donc, il faut que ça se
traite au niveau européen. Et
donc, tu rejoins le point de vue de
notre président solaire.
Voilà. faire un emprunt européen.
Oui, mais
tu as vu la tête des Allemands ?
Oui, j'ai vu la tête des Allemands. Et
donc là aussi, il faut être cohérent. Ça
n'aura enfin ça aura plus de chance
d'aboutir si on s'est démontré à nos
petits camarades de jeu européens que on
sait
redresser nos finances publiques.
Donc le chien court après sa queue pour
rester dans des métaphores canines.
Ouais. J'ai l'impression qu'on a plus
beaucoup de queue d'ailleurs. Non,
on s'est fait couper la queue. Paire de
souveraineté.
On a plus droit.
Comment
plus le droit de couper la queue des ch
heureux et les oreilles non plus.
Tu as pas l'impression que nos petits
amis allemands et nos nos petits amis
polonais, ils veulent un peu prendre le
contrôle des choses que nos boîtes
françaises se sont fait mettre un
collier étrangleur, que EDF s'est fait
tu as fait du rugby. Donc ils nous ont
fait des plaquages par tous les moyens
pour que EDF soit relégué.
Tu as pas l'impression que déléguer tout
notre pouvoir français à l'Europe avec,
excuse-moi de parler comme ça, mais
c'est pas les couteaux les plus affutés
du tiroir en terme de prospective et
stratégie. Ils ont pas vu la guerre
venir la guerre avec les Russes. Ils
l'ont pas vu venir. Ils ont fait une
stratégie énergétique. On entendait
encore là en 202 en 2021 ou en 2022
l'anas qui était en charge de l'énergie
dire c'est une guerre énergétique mais
vous inquiétez pas nous avons un plan.
Là en 2026 les industries allemandes et
énergivor tu as 90 % des des boîtes
énergivor allemandes qui vont [__] les
voiles ailleurs parce que elles sont en
train de canner. Donc déléguer notre
pouvoir à l'Europe quand tu vois la les
chips les moins croustillantes du paquet
à l'Europe incapacité à à de de les
remettre en question, ils sont au-dessus
de tout, ils sont dans leur tour
d'ivoire et derrière tu vois des boîtes
canées, des gens ne plus se chauffer, le
prix de la bouffe qui explose.
Ouais, enfin on est pas tout à fait là
quand même. Non
non mais attends, tu as des pays Non non
ne fait pas supporter à l'Europe euh des
faiblesses ou des erreurs qui pour
beaucoup sont franco-françaises.
Quand tu regardes le taux de croissance
de la Pologne enfin euh ça laisse
rêveur. Le ta le taux de croissance de
l'Espagne, ça laisse rêveur. La capacité
commun tout ça qu'est-ce qui est commun
à l'Espagne et la Poléone ? L'énergie
sont des pays de l'Union européenne si
je me trompe pas. D'accord. L'Espagne
est sortie est sorti de
et le Portugal aussi. Mais c'est pas ça.
Pourqu tu sais pourquoi ils sont sortis
? Bah sur le sujet de la connexion
d'interconnexion avec le le réseau
européen.
Ouais. Si tu mettais le prix de
l'énergie au Portugal en Espagne avec
nous, ce qu'on a pris dans les dents.
Non non mais c'était des révolutions
dans la rue, ça c'est autre chose. Mais
ça n'est pas la seule ni même la
principale explication d'un taux de
croissance de l'Espagne qui est trois
fois supérieur au nôtre en 2025 avec des
perspectives 2026 qui sont bonnes et ça
n'est pas l'ex loin sans faux. Ça n'est
pas l'explication du spectaculaire
redressement des finances publiques
portugaises. C'est absolument dingue ce
qui s'est passé au Portugal. Ouais, mais
enfin moi j'ai j'ai revu mon homologue
patronal portugais il y a il y a 10
jours. Le type est sur un nuage. C'est
formidable. La main d'œuvre revient, ils
augmentent les salaires mais ça passe
les doigts dans le nez. Le l'État est en
excédent budgétaire comme quoi tout est
possible. La Pologne, j'évoqué la
Pologne. La Pologne est sur euh sur un
traî de croissance de 3 %.
Charbon.
Ouais. Enfin, ils ont 5 % d'effort de
défense.
Bon euh
et ainsi de suite. L'Italie a une
croissance atune et et ne se réforme pas
autant qu'elle devrait se réformer. Bon,
il n'en meur pas moins que en l'espace
de 2 ans, ils sont passés de 7,2 à moins
de 3 % de déficit public et c'est des
pays européens. Donc faut pas dire que
l'Europe nous condamne en définitive à
avoir des performances
euh médiocres. Je reste prudent en
disant médiocre. Donc il y a il y a un
coefficient, il y a un qucient
franco-français qui est quand même
considérable qui est singulièrement lié
au fait qu'on est infoutu infoutu de
maîtriser nos dépenses sociales. Infoutu
à un moment donné ça va être les preuves
de vérité. Mais euh et là où je suis pas
d'accord avec toi non plus, c'est que
autant au niveau français effectivement
on manque cruellement d'une d'un plan
stratégique autant il existe à l'échelle
européenne. Il y a même deux rapports
Dragy et l'État tout est écrit dans
Dragy et l'État tout est écrit. Alors,
ce qui est extraordinaire, c'est que en
particulier le rapport Dragui était
endossé par la Commission européenne.
Maintenant, faudrait peut-être passer à
l'acte. C'est c'est ça le vrai problème.
Et donc, tu te heures un problème qui
qui à la limite moins un problème de
volonté politique que de fonctionnement
institutionnel. C'est c'est ça devient
ingérable cette Union européenne à 27.
Donc il faut il faut des il faut c'était
suggéré d'ailleurs
ça va s'améliorer. On va faire rentrer
l'Ukraine.
Ouais. Bon je doute qu'on fasse rentrer
l'Ukraine. Non mais
pourquoi ? Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que d'abord je pense pas que
ça contribuerait à l'apaisement de la
relation avec la Russie.
Les Russes ils s'en foutent. Les Russes
ils ont dit clairement si l'Europe veut
rentrer dans si l'Ukraine veut rentrer
dans l'Europe tant mieux.
Non ils n'ont pas dit ça.
Si si ils ont dit par contre l'OTAN non.
Ouais ouais enfin même l'Europe, j'ai
pas compris ça. Si
si si ils ont dit oui oui, vas-y rentre.
Ouais bon euh et du coup je sais plus de
quoi on parlait. Euh
non, mais il faut il faut des majorités
qualifiées et il faut il faut des des
politiques alors le avec une grosse
limite, il faut des des politiques euh
sur des des pactes volontaires à
l'intérieur de de l'Union européenne. La
limite du raisonnement, c'est que à ce
jour, ça se fera sans la France. Ce qui
est en train de se passer entre
l'Allemagne et l'Italie, c'est quand
même un warning incroyable
dans entre des gouvernements qui ont
rien à voir entre eux.
un latin et un germanique.
Ouais. Et je ne perds jamais une
occasion de rappeler que l'Allemagne est
dirigée plus ou moins bien mais quand
même par une coalition associant des
socialistes.
Et donc quand je croise nos socialistes,
je leur dis écoutez vous n'êtes pas les
mêmes de part et d'autres durin.
Ça doit être
c'est un peu c'est un peu taquin de ma
part.
Bon on fait une expérience de pensée.
Ouais. Donc imagine-toi, tu as une
grosse boîte qui fait un certain nombre
de millions, tu t'imagines hein. Et il y
a la guerre. Est-ce que tu as fait un
scénario de stress test sur ta boîte
pour résister à la guerre ?
Non.
Ah bah tu déconnes.
Non non non, j'ai pas fait je t'affirme
que
parce que tu veux pas y croire.
Quand tu vois notre chef d'étatmajor
commencer à prévenir nos mères entre les
lignes, bon les gars, on a vendu
d'autres toutes nos casernes, on a pas
de quoi loger nos nos soldats, il va
falloir trouver des solutions
alternatives pour sur vos régions, vos
villages pour loger nos soldats. Bon,
déjà qu'il y a des problèmes de
logement, mais ça nous a fait un peu
marrer. Euh quand tu vois notre chef
d'étatmajor parler aux autres corps
d'armée, dire bon, il faut quand même se
préparer. Quand tu vois les Allemands,
les Anglais dire "Bon, il faut quand
même se préparer aussi à l'échelle
individuelle, on parle patron patron".
D'accord. Tu as fait un un scénario de
stress test exploratoire de la le
conflit sur nos boîtes. Alors, quand tu
vois Renault faire des petits drones, on
a l'habitude que nos boîtes d'automobile
fassent de l'armement. Ça nous rappelle
des époques un peu sanglantes.
Ouais.
Est-ce que au MEDF on se pose la
question de notre tissu de boîte ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si la guerre ?
Non non non. Alors bon mais c'est pas à
l'échelle, j'en suis parfaitement
conscient. On avance quand même sur
cette fameuse BD, base industrielle et
technologique de défense euh qui se
structure progressivement. Enfin, le
ruissellement des crédits publics
tardif, on va dire, hein. Euh mais on n'
pas de on n pas ben je vais m'y mettre,
on n pas
travaillé un scénario de guerre à pour
en parler. Après, quelle serait la forme
de la guerre ? Quelle serait son ampleur
? Bon, ça, j'en sais rien, mais il faut
effectivement qu'on y travaille. Alors,
j'essaie de retomber sur mes pattes en
disant que ma boîte, ma propre boîte a
traversé trois guerres. Donc la guerre
de 70, bon, la guerre de
1870. Oui oui oui. J'ai pas encore revu
de guerre en 1970 mais bon ça pu
m'échapper.
Ça s'appelle un choc pétrolier.
Ouais. Euh oui. Et d'ailleurs deux chocs
pétroliers 73 79 plus la crise
énergétique consécutive au conflit en
Ukraine. Bon
pe te faire passer pour un vieux
l'espace d'une seule.
Ouais. Ouais. Donc la guerre de 1870, la
guerre de 1914, la deuxième guerre
mondiale. Bon alors je dis pas qu'elle
est à l'abri de tout ma boîte mais je sa
quel point elle a failli disparaître.
Donc raison de plus pour travailler sur
ce scénario catastrophe.
Quelle est la forme la plus aboutie de
la guerre ?
Tu es patron hein. Puis tu m'as dit tu
viens de me dire que tu as résisté à
1870.
Ouais ça se voit. Euh [rires]
ta protèse de hanche.
Ouais.
que je t'ai pas encore.
Quelle est la forme la plus aboutie de
la guerre ?
Alors, je sais pas si je comprends bien
la guerre économique.
Ouais.
Donc, est-ce que tu as fait un stress
test des boîtes françaises en cas de
scénario de guerre économique ?
Non.
Qu'est-ce que vous attendez les gars ?
On va s'y mettre.
Alors, on va passer
à la forme la moins aboutie de la
guerre.
Boum ! Poum ! Pampan, la poudre, chaîne
logistique.
Ouais.
Tu as fait un phénomène de stress test
de ta boîte pour la guerre archaïque ?
Non mais
chaîne logistique énergétique,
on y travaille tous de manière plus ou
moins consciente.
Tu veux de la crème solaire aussi quand
tu me dis ça ?
Ouais. Euh non, mais je veux dire, on
est on est sous la contrainte, on va
dire, on a on est tous en train de
revoir nos chaînes de valeur. Les
fameuses chaînes de valeur. Ouais. Oui,
si quand même c'est c'est
significatif.
Alors ça renvoie à plein de sujets.
C'est pas ta question mais je le glisse
au passage. Les traités de libre
échange.
La la France est dans une forme là aussi
de déniogique.
Démagogique.
Donc ça fait partie du du débat. Moi ce
que je vois dans ma propre boîte, c'est
que on a une dépendance en particulier à
la Chine qui était assez forte sur un
certain nombre d'approvisionnements
et qui est en train de diminuer très
significativement parce que tu as des tu
as de des des réimplantations de sites
de production en Europe ou en Afrique du
Nord ou en Turquie qui dans l'absolu
sont sans doute moins critiques que si
on continuait à avoir cette dépendance.
Après euh il y a un autre enjeu bien
franco-français qui est de savoir si oui
ou non on veut exploiter nos ressources
naturel.
Moi, j'ai les idées très claires
là-dessus. Euh
alors
bah il faut le faire il faut le faire
évidemment. Oui. Non mais tu vois pour
illustrer mon propos euh dès des mon
élection, je me suis rendu à Échassière,
magnifique localité de l'Allié euh où
euh sous d'ailleurs une mine exploitée à
ciel ouvert, une mine de Caola.
Euh en exploitation depuis 150 ans, il y
a un énorme gisement de lithium. Bon, on
a un opérateur qui est prêt à mettre
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus sous réserve
que le cours du lithium se redresse un
petit peu. Euh et bien quand j'y suis
allé, ça devait être à l'automne 2023,
il y avait déjà des camionnettes de
gendarmerie dans un endroit absolument
charmant. Mais je comment dire les
choses, c'est assez c'est assez rural.
Donc tu t'attends pas à trouver des
camionnettes de gendarmerie là. Pourquoi
était-elle là ? Pour prévenir
l'installation de Zadist.
Bon euh
tu as le ce projet de mine de TXT de
réactivation de la mine de TXTel de
Salot au programme dans l'Ariège
Rebelotte et 10 de il y a déjà des
activistes qui sont prépositionnés pour
au cas où le projet serait effectivement
mis en œuvre s'y opposé et des exemples
comme ça on en a des on en a des
palenqués.
C'est quoi ton valet de pic pour gérer
tout ça ? Ben mon valet de pic, c'est je
leur dis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure,
qu'on identifie mieux qui sont ces
gens-là, qu'on leur coupl les vives
parce que dans un certain nombre de cas,
tu as derrière des puissances privées ou
étatiques, hein. Je me garde dans faire
une généralité mais quand même ça s'est
vérifié dans un certain nombre de cas
euh qu'ensuite euh les règles de droit
soient respectées. Je prends un autre
exemple. Alors, c'est pas
c'est pas sur un enjeu stratégique.
Quand tu as un magnifique industriel
breton qui est prêt à investir 500
millions d'euros, créer 250 emplois
directs, non pardon, investir 250
millions d'euros, créer 500 emplois
directs, 500 emplois indirects dans son
département d'origine envil qu'il a
coché toutes les cases, rempl toutes les
procédures,
des brioches.
Voilà.
Euh, on parle du même et qui à la fin on
a marre, on a marre parce que il y a des
il y a des comités théodule qui
s'improvisent matin, midi et soir pour
contrarier son projet. À la fin, il dit
"Ben, je vais pas faire mon projet, il
restera pour le que les yeux pour
pleurer." Mais le fait générateur, c'est
Notre Dame des Landes.
C'est Notre Dame des Landes. C'est c'est
une c'est une capitulation de l'État
devant une voix de fête.
Tu parles de l'aéroport. Ben bien sûr.
Et comme par enchantement,
est-ce que je peux me faire l'avocat du
diable ?
Ouais.
Notre Dame Lénand, il y avait un triton.
Ouais. Bah
et attends, Notredame des Landes,
c'était un beau bocage.
Ouais, sûrement.
Notredame des Landes, une région
magnifique. Et puis le transport aérien,
il est pas censé baisser.
Ouais, il est en train de baisser en
France.
Euh pas ailleurs. Bon non mais après que
qu'on est je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'on fasse ce choix collectif de la
décroissance.
OK mais il faut le dire et il faut
l'assumer des toilettes sèch toi
j'espère.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais
comment
peut-on satisfaire la demande
systématique de nos concitoyens qui est
le pouvoir d'achat et s'inscrire dans
une trajectoire qui nécessairement
conduit à l'appauvrissement ? Alors, je
veux pas dire que l'appauvrissement
c'est le malheur, mais si le bonheur
c'est le pouvoir d'achat, ben il faut
répondre à cette demande. Donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut générer de la richesse.
Donc si tu te privincture, si tu
renonces à exploiter tes ressources
naturelles dont les ressources
agricoles,
si tu te mets à l'écart de ce qui se
passe à travers le monde en matière de
technologie, d'infrastructure, de
transport et cetera et cetera, à un
moment donné
ça boucle plus. Donc moi je pense qu'il
faut poser les problèmes de manière très
très systématique, très complète, très
exhaustive et très constructive. C'est
la raison pour laquelle moi j'ai proposé
à mes camarades syndiqués avec lesquels
j'ai une bonne relation, je ne croise
pas les bras, je leur ai dit bah
écoutez, on va travailler sur le modèle
productif. Alors le truc peut paraître
complètement me fait pas de diversion
là. On parlait de stress test de la
guerre et guerre économique.
Ouais. Oui. Non mais
parce que les c'est facile.
Mais non.
Non non,
on verra les adistes plus tard.
Non, mais c'est le même sujet.
OK. Les c'est les adistes, pas que mais
en bonne partie qui qui s'oppose à
à ce qu'on exploite des ressources
minières qu'on a chez nous. Il y a du
protège,
il y a du Ah oui,
la nature.
Bah oui, ben il renforce notre
dépendance. Pour qui travaille-t-il ?
On a du lithium dans l'allié. On a du
lithium sous une autre forme. En Alsace,
on a de l'or en Guyane.
On a de l'or en Guyane. La montagne
d'or,
on a on a du gaz à côté de Mayotte.
Est-ce que tu es allé en Guyane ?
Euh, pas récemment.
Bon, moi j'y suis allé à plusieurs
reprises, y compris pour des raisons
personnelles. Et je suis allé visiter la
seule mine légale exploitée en Guyane au
finf front de la jungle. Enfin, c'est
c'est assez
exigeant.
Je te vois bien en short et en pierrog.
Ouais. euh sous un déluge de flotte. Euh
donc on n' pas donné suite au projet de
la montagne d'or. Bien euh enfin il n'a
échappé à personne qui avait des
orpailleurs partout illégaux euh qui au
passage utilisent des substances
strictement interdites. Bon euh mais
c'est toujours le même raisonnement.
C'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on veut ? Bon euh donc moi je suis
très
très déterminé là-dessus. On a
effectivement des
gisements d'hydrocarbure
qu'on ne veut pas exploiter.
Bon, un contact
mais il faut pas demander du pouvoir
d'achat.
Tu parles de pouvoir d'achat et
il faut pas demander pardon euh de la
souveraineté.
Euh
donc le le vrai problème, c'est qu'on
narrive pas à poser tous ces sujets-là
d'une manière d'une manière stratégique.
Pouvoir d'achat, c'est pouvoir à
survivre, pouvoir à consommer de pouvoir
énergétique.
Non, moi je dis je vois pas les choses
comme ça. Je je pense qu'une immense
majorité de nos concitoyens veulent prim
qu'on leur foute la paix,
qu'on arrête de les emmerder matin, midi
et soir par des contraintes, des
réglementations, des contrôles, j'en
passé des meilleurs et euh de manière
très raisonnable et raisonnée se faire
plaisir. Voilà. Euh donc ils veulent
pouvoir se loger convenablement, ils
veulent pouvoir manger à peu près ce
qu'ils veulent. Après, c'est leur
liberté individuelle de choisir un
aliment plutôt qu'un autre dans la
limite de leurs moyens. bien sûr, ils
veulent pouvoir se déplacer enfin euh
qu'on revienne à une vie normale. Voilà,
c'est c'est ça que je comprends dans le
pouvoir d'achat. Alors après, la notion
de pouvoir d'achat, c'est pas la même
selon le selon la catégorie
sociop-professionnelle, mais je persiste
et signe. Nos concitoyens sont des gens
plein de bon sens qui ont envie de vivre
calmement, calmement dans un pays dont
ils sont fiers.
Stress test, guerre, guerre économique.
Ouais. Euh, tu veux de la crème solaire
un peu ?
Ouais,
c'est quand même préoccupant.
Mais bien sûr.
Attends, nous on a anticipé la guerre
avec Popof 1, Popof 2, Popof 3 à partir
de 2015.
H
on a conseillé quelques boîtes en leur
disant "Méfiez-vous les gars, votre
chaîne d'approvisionnement, le coût de
l'énergie, ça va être un peu tendu. Tu
veux du titane toi ? Réveille,
réveille-toi un peu. On l'armée un peu
comme le MDF, ils ont pas senté le truc
venir. Même la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du coton pour les
bourdus, ils se sont retrouvé un peu
bourré.
Il faut peut-être un petit peu s'énerver
les gars là. Est-ce que l'État vous aide
?
Non.
Est-ce que tu vois des militaires passer
chez toi en disant "Bon, alors s'il y a
la guerre avec les Chinois et les
Russes, qu'est-ce qui se passe
?" Non, mais dans le dans dans sur la
fameuse BETD, mais pas pas plus
systématiquement. et je le rejoins. Bon
euh en réalité si c'est la guerre, tous
les secteurs sont impactés. Donc à un
moment donné bouffer ou tu peux plus te
vêtir ou tu peux plus. OK.
Donc on va s'y mettre.
Méfie-toi. Ça arrive parce que qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit le chef d'étatmajor ? Il a
dit pour quelle année ? 2029230.
Oui mais
on voit ça plus vers 2027.
Ouais ouais.
Non mais il faut évidemment s'y préparer
de là à considérer que c'est
inéluctable. J'en suis pas là. Bon, on
croise les doigts pour que tu as raison
et on croise les doigts pour qu'on est
tort.
On arrive pratiquement à la fin de notre
interview. Est-ce que tu as un sujet que
tu souhaiterais traiter
avant que je pose les questions de la
communauté ?
Vas-y.
Non, réfléchis.
Je prends je prends la première.
que je découvre avec toi. D'accord.
Pourquoi le MEDEF a-t-il
systématiquement soutenu les différents
traités européens, l'élargissement de
l'Union européenne et la monnaie unique
qui ont laminé le tissu industriel
français en particul en particulier
celui de des PME ? Et pourquoi
militent-il pour le pour plus de pouvoir
pour la Commission européenne via la
Fédération qui le représente Business
Europe ? Merci de ne pas faire une
réponse bullshit du type l'Europe doit
être moins bureaucratique. Ce sont les
normes qui tuent la compétitivité de nos
entreprises. Question de Camille,
je reprends ce que je disais tout à
l'heure.
Ta réponse bullshit.
Non, ma réponse c'est qu'à l'intérieur
de l'Union européenne, il y a des pays
qui par définition sont soumis aux mêmes
règles que nous et qui s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux. Donc ne mettons pas sur
le dos de l'Europe des responsabilités
qui sont les nôtres. Premier point. Euh
2è point euh
le le le le problème c'est pas l'Europe
elle-même, c'est c'est l'inertie de
l'Europe.
Moi, je vois mal comment la France
Alors, il y a une exception qui est un
qui est un irritant que je connais
particulièrement bien parce que je suis
frontalier de ce pays. Je parle de la
Suisse
mais c'est un modèle complètement
différent. C'est pas frontalier.
Pardon ? Moi je suis de l' moi.
D'accord.
Mon siège est à Bourgambresse si tu veux
tout savoir.
Il a un joli crêpse là-bas. Non.
Oui. [rires]
Ils sont de la limonade et du chocolat.
Non
non. Ouais. Non. On fait des trucs
formidables. Mais mais je peux on peut
refaire une émission là-dessus. Euh
d'ailleurs, je recommande la lecture du
de la biographie de Paul Bocus qui vient
de sortir. Il était pas de là mais bon
c'est c'est pas grave.
Il y a des Halles non ?
À Lyon. Ouais. Al Paul Buse euh
il était polygame aussi non ?
Oui. Oui. Mais mais ouvertement
polygame. Donc bon euh le modèle suisse
est très différent et c'est un modèle
très industriel. Beaucoup s'imaginent
que c'est le pays de la banque et de de
du recyclage de l'argent sale. C'est pas
vrai.
Démontre démontre
et ça c'est vrai pour le coup. Et
d'ailleurs les c'est on forme en France
des palanquées de de jeunes au lycée
horlog lycée professionnel horlogé de
Besançon qui séance tenant vont
travailler à la chaude fond de l'autre
côté de la frontière.
Lip,
pardon,
Lipe.
Bah lipet de ses cendres, mais enfin
c'est plutôt
euh quoi qu'il en soit
euh
ça ça offense mon cœur de patriote. Je
je pense être un sincère patriote, mais
il y a des sujets pour lesquels la
France n'a pas l'échelle en définitive
pour tenir tête
l'Union des marchés de capitaux
français. On a pardon, on a on a un
système financier français qui est
incroyable, incroyable, de robustesse et
et qui se se place très bien d'ailleurs
au niveau mondial, les assurances, les
banques. OK. Mais c'est pas le à elle
seule l'épargne française qui va nous
permettre de développer l'intelligence
artificielle,
le quantique et cetera au rythme et à
l'échelle auquelle il faudrait le faire.
C'est à l'échelle européenne d'évidence.
C'est à l'échelle européenne.
Pas de plan calcul quoi.
Bah un peu daté le plan calcul puis on
en connaît les résultats brillants
à
bid.
Question internet. Je demande à la
communauté sur Twitter de liker les
questions que vous avez envie qu'on
pose. Ça nous évitera de faire les 52
questions à la chaîne.
Le MDEF défend une croissance qui dépend
à 95 % d'une énergie abondante et bon
marché que l'Europe n'a plus. Sans un
plan de contraction volontaire et
coordonné, vous ne gérez pas une
économie mais l'inertie d'un cash dont
les entrepris de quoi ? D'un crash,
pardon. Mais l'inertie d'un crash dont
les entreprises seront les premières
victimes. À quel niveau de rationnement
énergétique vos modèles de rentabilité
cessent-il mathématiquement d'exister ?
Non mais tu as cru que tu étais où là ?
On n'est pas sur une chaîne YouTube
beauté ici hein.
Ah là c'est très très savant ça.
Donc je te la refais.
Ouais.
OK. Le MDEF, ça tu connais ?
Bon,
jusque-là, ça va.
Tu me fais pas d'avc jusqu'à la fin de
la question, hein. Le MDEF défend une
croissance qui dépend à 95 % d'une
énergie abondante et bon marché que
l'Europe n'a plus. Tu comprends jusque
là ?
Ouais, je suis pas d'accord mais bon,
on verra ça.
Sur le Vas-y,
je continue la suite de la question.
Sans un plan de contraction volontaire
et coordonné, vous ne gérez pas une
économie mais l'inertie d'un crash dont
les entreprises seront les premières
victimes. Question : À quel niveau de
rationnement énergétique vos modèles de
rentabilité cessent-il mathématiquement
d'exister ? C'est c'est
je te le fais simple.
Ouais. Non mais je crois avoir compris
mais vas-y vas-y vasy. Reformule
reformule. Ouais.
En gros, ta boîte, si ton énergie tu la
touches plus marché et que tes taux
d'intérêt sont au plafond et que tu peux
plus refinancer ton bordelou
et que ton énergie pour produire, tu te
fais manger par les Américains et les
Chinois,
à partir de quel moment tu es tellement
plus rentable que tu craches ?
Mais non, mais c'est t tous les scénaris
sont envisageables mais la réalité à ce
jour,
on dit scénaris ou scénario ?
Scénario des scénaris, tac mon côté
latiniste ne me cherche pas trop
là-dessus. Euh latin,
je crois. Mais
formidable, c'est quelle base ?
Attends, le la réalité la réalité c'est
quoi ? C'est que on a une croissance
insuffisante maison a quand même une
croissance et on regarde, on a une
consommation d'énergie qui est flat.
Bon, ça va sans doute pas assez vite
mais on en terme d'efficience
énergétique, on est en train d'accélérer
très fort. Premier point.
Attends, elle est flat. Mais tu as vu le
prix de l'énergie ?
Et ça n'enlève rien en fait qu'on a eu
de la croissance.
À quel prix ?
Mais en terme de dette.
Non mais c'est
intriqué hein.
Non non ça n'a rien à voir. Mais non la
Pologne sort ses 3 % de croissance.
L'Espagne je ne parle plus de l'Espagne
parce que tu as raison. elle s'est
déconnectée. Mais enfin non, on peut
parler de l'Espagne parce que finalement
elle est elle se elle s'approvisionne
massivement avec des énergies
renouvelables et manifestement ça lui
pose pas de problème.
Quelques instabilités en terme de
blackout.
Oui. Oui. Non mais c'est pour ça on est
pour le la neutralité technologique et
un mix énergétique diversifié. OK, mais
c'est pas le sujet. Donc euh le le le la
question, si je la comprends bien, n'a
de sens que si tu considères que euh
on a aucune perspective aucune
perspective euh de d'améliorer notre
efficience énergétique, ce qui est
démontré enfin l'inverse est démontré.
Donc je moi je comprends pas ça. C'est
c'est toute chose égale par ailleurs. La
catastrophe est inéluctable. Mais c'est
pas toute chose par ailleurs. Toute
chose égale par ailleurs. Alors si je
suis bien ton raisonnement
notre efficience énergétique
Ouais.
Ça voudrait dire qu'on consomme moins de
pétrole et qu'on consomme moins de
charbon.
Ouais.
Tu as regardé les courbes de croissance
de consommation de charbon et de pétrole
dans le monde ?
Oui dans le monde.
Bah oui mais je parle de la France et de
l'Europe là.
Oui. Ça s'appelle une récession.
Mais pourquoi ? Parce que quand tu
consommes moins d'énergie, c'est pas que
tu es plus efficient, tu fais semblant.
Mais on a une croissance en Europe à
quel tarif 1 et demi%. Non, je parle de
l'Europe, je parle pas de la France. On
a une croissance en Europe qui était un
peu doppée, il faut le dire par
l'Irlande. Enfin, on a une croissance de
1,5 %. C'est pas assez, mais c'est pas
de la récession. Est-ce que la
consommation d'énergie en Europe a
augmenté ? Non.
Donc, je pense qu'on est en train
d'enclencher ce cycle. Je pense et je
souhaite, on est en train d'enclencher
ce cycle où euh l'efficience énergétique
et la frugalité,
Oh, je vais t'attraper, vas-y, continue.
Ouais. Nous permettront de concilier en
définitive la décarbonation et la
croissance. Il y a pas de fatalité.
Donc, on est on est stagnant en terme de
consommation énergétique, si je t'ai
bien si j'ai bien compris.
Mais c'est avéré.
Et en terme de production de dette,
on est stagnant ou pas ?
En France, non. Et en Europe,
en Europe, on Mais c'est pas tout à fait
par hasard que je je citais le cas de
l'Italie, que je citais le cas du
Portugal. On peut dire c'est un petit
pays, c'est pas intéressant. Est-ce que
les Est-ce que les finances publiques
allemandes dérivent ?
Il prévoit il prévient il prévoi combien
de de dettes en plus les Allemands là ?
Un plan de réarmement à combien de
milliards ? Mais
non, mais c'est pas tellement le plan
d'armement, c'est leur plan de relance
globalement à 800 milliards.
Voilà. Mais ils en ont les moyens
parce qu'ils ont un taux d'endettement à
60 % 70 60
64 dire.
Donc je pense qu'on mélange on mélange
tout là. Et donc les Allemands lancent
leur plan de relance infrastructure
armement industrie. Très bien. Quel est
le rapport avec le prix de l'énergie ?
Je je comprends pas.
Non, je
pose la question à Audi Volkswagen, ils
vont t'expliquer avec des des crayons de
couleur. Question internet.
Non, je vois à peu près ce que
Bon,
question internet que je découvre avec
toi. Quelle est la position sur la
propagande liée à la concentration des
médias mainstream auprès d'Oligar qui
ont profité de largesse de nos
représentants pour acquérir des biens
publics rendus volontairement
dysfonctionnels ?
ou
euh
si je comprends bien la question parce
qu'elle est vraiment très très savante
en tout cas
ou un peu mal tourné mais
euh moi je je n'arrive pas à me
convaincre qu'il y a un oligopole de
l'information en France
euh
d'autant plus que on parle des médias
traditionnels. Enfin
pour vieux quoi.
Non mais on a la démonstration à
l'instant quoi. Il y a des médias qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'alternative qui
sauf erreur de ma part pèsent plus
maintenant que les médias traditionnels.
Donc est-ce qu'on joue pas à se faire
peur
en s'imaginant que il y a un monopole ou
un oligopole sur les médias d'une
manière générale ? Je ne le crois pas.
Je Il me demande de sortir deux morceaux
de sucre. Vous êtes méchants. Patrick il
est gentil. Il est venu là. On l'a pas
tiré par les cheveux. Tu connais la la
blague des deux morceaux de sucre chez
nous ?
Non.
Tu as déjà essayé de te mettre à genou
sur deux morceaux de sucre sous les
rotules ? Mais
j'imagine que c'est désagréable.
Très surtout pendant pendant 2 heures.
Je remonte le fil des questions que
j'actualise. Pendant ce temps-là, tu vas
réfléchir au sujet que tu aimerais
aborder avec nous queon n pas abordé.
Je t'écoute.
Vas-y, aide-moi. Là, il un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder qu'on a pas abordé.
Ah mais moi c'est je l'ai abordé du
coup.
Un sujet hyper important queon pas
abordé. Mais mais c'est se redoter d'une
d'une classe politique au bon niveau.
Voilà. Donc plus de cumul enfin
réautoriser le cumul des mandats, payer
mieux nos élus, ne pas les emmerder
matin, midi et soir quand ils quittent
leurs fonctions politiques et qu'
peuvent pas se reasser dans le dans le
civil. On va dire ça comme ça. Moi, je
connais précisément des gens de grande
qualité
qui ont renoncé à faire de la politique
en disant "C'est un sac d'emmerdement
sans fin." Et ben je pense que c'est une
perte pour la collectivité que ces
gens-là se soient détournés de carrière
politique. Alors euh et on est dans une
démocratie jusqu'à preuve du contraire.
Il faut redonner du poids au politique
et il faut réhausser le niveau du
politique. Je j'en suis convaincu et je
suis convaincu que ça réglerait beaucoup
de choses.
Bon je la pose mais tu as à moitié
répondu mais je la pose quand même pour
la bravoure de la question. Arrêtez
d'emmerder les Français entre guillemets
disait Pompidou.
Ouais.
Être entrepreneur en France est un
processus du combattant et l'ensemble de
ce parcours est largement démoralisant.
Les règles du jeu sont sans cesse en
évolution et de plus en plus complexes.
Comment inverser cette tendance ?
Je suis d'abord d'accord parce que je
suis praticien.
Bon non mais tu vois je je glissais tout
à l'heure
je glissais tout à l'heure. J'étais
bénévole au MDF. Ça me ça m'occupe
beaucoup de temps mais je suis avant
toute chose chef d'entreprise donc je
souffre dans ma chair.
Je pense que euh
alors il faut d'abord redonner du
pouvoir au local y compris au préfet.
J'ai beaucoup de respect pour le corps
préfectoral.
Euh ensuite, il faut élaguer une
palanqué de de d'agences
euh qui s'empilent en réalité et qui
refont un travail que les
administrations centrales devraient
faire. Et surtout, il faut queon ait en
amont des décisions législatives ou
réglementaires systématiquement une
étude d'impact et que on ait ensuite à
un intervalle relativement court, une
mesure d'impact.
Ça renvoie ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure. Tu as des gens qui en â et
conscience animés par de bons
sentiments, prennent des dispositions
législatives ou réglementaire qui leur
paraissent pertinentes et qui se
révèlent inefficaces ou pire encore
désastreuses. Et bien, il faut mesurer
ces conséquences et que les gens qui ont
pris ces décisions en soient
responsables. Je pense que ça calmera
les ardeurs.
Tu connais Harry Seldon ?
Non.
La psychohistoire.
Bon, je te pose une question de Harry.
Combien de subvention d'argent public
nous coûtera la fin des délocalisations
d'emploi à l'étranger du MEDEV ? Pour
interrogation avec une petite coupure de
presse qui dit assister 270 milliards
d'aide aux entreprises de points.
Un nouveau chiffrage révèle l'ampleur du
pillage patronal. Chaque année, 270
milliards d'euros d'argent public sont
versés aux entreprises.
Bien sûr. Bien sûr.
Est-ce que c'est une façon de
courtcircuiter l'Europe et de doper nos
entreprises pour une mondialisation qui
est très agressive ?
Tout ça est un tissu de mensonge. Alors,
je suis très à l'aise pour en parler
parce que je suis à son invitation, je
suis allé me confronter avec le
rapporteur spécial du Sénat sur le
comment il s'appelle ?
Fabien Guer, sénateur communiste de la
scène Saint-Denis qui d'ailleurs est un
est un homme tout à fait intéressant.
Tout ça est est une énorme baudruche,
c'est totalement faux. À la fin des
fins, déduction faite de ces
compensation, les entreprises françaises
sont les deuxièmes au sein de l'OCDE en
terme en terme de prélèvement
obligatoire. Alors, sauf à me démontrer
que l'arithmétique n'a plus court, hein,
je je serais ravi d'échanger plus
précisément sur ce sujet-là. Euh les les
chiffres sont les chiffres, c'est du
grand n'importe quoi. Quant au non pas
270 milliards mais 211 milliards
qu'avait chiffré euh le même sénateur
Gay euh il y a des choses
extraordinaires là-dedans qui n'ont rien
à voir avec des aides aux entreprises.
Enfin typiquement le le taux de TVA
réduit sur la restauration ou sur la
rénovation thermique des logements, il y
a pas un chiffrelin qui tombe dans la
poche des entreprises, c'est les
consommateurs finaux. Donc les ménages.
Alors si les ménages disent "Je veux
payer mon restaurant plus cher ou je
veux payer mes travaux de rénovation
énergétique plus cher", c'est leur c'est
leur liberté hein. Donc voilà, mais
c'est de la caricature de ces faux
débats qu'on a en France. Et à la fin,
je leur dis, les entreprises, c'est 12,5
% à peu près du PIB, les entreprises
supportent les prélèvements obligatoire
les plus élevés du monde après la Suède.
le tu as pas l'impression que le
gouvernement il il limite
l'image de casse de la France en disant
oui, il y a plein d'entreprises qui se
créent, la réindustrialisation de la
France et que il se il s'envoi de des
paillettes.
Tu as pas l'impression que si on
enlevait ces auto-entrepreneurs qui font
des livraisons de pizza à gogo, le
chiffre des entreprises créées, elle
serait plus en chute libre ? Non, tu as
pas
Non. deux éléments de réponse mais tu
les connais depuis la dissolution, c'est
vrai qu'on a un solde négatif
d'implantation d'usine. Alors c'est
moins vrai, ça n'est d'ailleurs pas vrai
en terme de de capitaux investis mais il
y a beaucoup de en tout cas en
intention, il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
est fléché vers les data centers qui
sont pas approprement parlés des usines
sur l'entrepreneuriat.
Je pense que c'est un facteur
d'optimisme. Corriger corriger des
créations de micro-entreprises et en
proportion de la la population, la
France est le pays au monde où il se
crée le plus d'entreprises.
C'est plutôt sympathique. Étant rappelé
qu'il y a quoi il y a 30 ans,
massivement les jeunes voulaient devenir
fonctionnaires. Je suis là aussi à
l'aise. On a besoin de fonctionnair
peut-être pas d'autant que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui et probablement de meilleur
et au cas par cas mieux payé. Mais il y
a quand même une inversion
incroyablement positive dans le sens de
l'entrepreneuriat.
La remise en course des 35 he
c'est c'est pas le sujet prioritaire. Le
sujet prioritaire c'est l'âge de des
parts en retraite et pardon d'insister
lourdement mais avec une totale
conviction là-dessus c'est faire accéder
à l'emploi tous ces jeunes qui en sont
éloignés.
question internet et là et parce que à
la fin à la fin le sujet c'est le taux
d'emploi.
C'est le taux d'emploi. Quand on regarde
quand on regarde la durée moyenne
hebdomadaire de travail en France
avec les souplesses qui ont été
introduites au fil du temps, elle se
compare exactement à celle qu'on a en
Allemagne ou en Grande-Bretagne. Donc le
le vrai sujet c'est le temps de travail
dans la vie.
Question internet. Le MEDF comme le la
présidence Renaissance représente 20 %
de ceux pour lequels ils prennent des
décisions. Alors je je connais pas les
chiffres. On va dire qu'il a raison. Se
trouvent-ils légitimes pour
interrogation ? Ontent-ils peur eux
aussi de la vraie démocratie pour
interrogation ?
Alors je sais pas d'où sortent ces
chiffres, ils sont faux.
Alors après en France, il y a 5 millions
d'entreprises mais dont près de 3
millions de micro-entrepreneurs. Très
bien. Il y a combien d'entreprises qui
ont des salariés en France ?
Il en à peu près 1 million et demi. Bon
le MEDF
c'est plus de la moitié de l'emploi
salarié. 12 millions. Bon, donc dire que
le MEDF n'est pas représentatif, là je
comprends pas très bien.
Alors les je suis très relaxe sur ces
sujets là. C'est c'est là aussi il y a
la vérité des chiffres.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Des
livres qui ont été importants dans ton
cheminement intellectuel et des livres
que tu trouves nécessaire à lire pour
être bien câblé ?
Euh moi, il y a un livre que je relis
assez régulièrement qui
le livre de Bruno Lemire.
Ouais. Non. Euh 1793
qui est pas le bouquin le plus connu de
Victor Hugo mais que je trouve
incroyable et qui à mon avis est
d'actualité parce que ça explique
comment dans certaines circonstances une
société peut se déchirer
et il y a des gens qui en logique
devraient bien s'entendre et s'entendit
bien finissent par se détester au point
de se tuer. On vit des des choses
malheureusement un peu similaires ces
temps-ci. Euh après euh après euh
bon, j'ai quelques quelques bouquins de
de référence mais je vais parler des
d'un des derniers bouquins que j'ai lu.
J'ai évoqué la la biographie de Buse.
C'est des personnages extraordinaires.
Moi, j'aime bien les personnages
extraordinaires euh avec des des faces
des faces cachées ou en tout cas un peu
ombré mais euh et c'est pas ça peut ça
peut surprendre. Je viens de finir un
bouquin qui a été écrit par une amie que
je respecte infiniment, d'autant qu'elle
est à l'Académie française, Dominique
Bonin, qui a écrit un bouquin sur son
père qui a été que j'ai bien connu, qui
est un type de partie de rien et qui a
été dernier président de l'ORTF, tu
vois, on parlait de du monopole de
l'information. Voilà. Moi, j'aime bien
lire des trucs des trucs très divers
mais 1793 pour moi, c'est
Tu cuisines toi ?
Non.
Un lyonnais qui cuisine pas ? Je sais
faire deux choses pour autant que ça
demande à savoir. Ouvrir les huîtres, ce
qui est pas très lyonnais et faire la
fond du savoyarde. Donc c'est même pas
loin. C'est fond du savoard. Un
métier métier.
C'est un métier.
Tu mets du fil dedans.
Oui. Oui. Monsieur a des lettres.
[rires]
Est-ce que tu as un film ? Il a tout.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as un film à à
nous conseiller ?
Euh
Ah oui, tris fois.
Ouais. Je je vais malheureusement pas
beaucoup au cinéma. Moi, je suis allé
voir le le weekend dernier le match du
créelin parce que j'avais adoré le
bouquin. Euh c'est intéressant. C'est
intéressant. Euh oui, [rires]
bon un peu un peu décevant, c'est de mon
point de vue, c'est souvent le cas. Un
peu décevant par rapport au bouquin.
Euh d'autant que Jolen Poli, j'ai fait
intervenir à plusieurs reprises au
Médaf. Je trouve que c'est un type très
éclairant puis qui a une vraie culture
et beaucoup de recul par rapport au aux
événements. Euh donc le Ouais, le le
film pas mal.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
qui va rester impérissable sur le
réseau.
De ne pas se laisser gagner par cette
espèce de morosité ambiante que je
trouve débile. D'abord, ça mène à rien
et en plus, je pense que ça correspond
pas à la réalité.
Patrick Martin, merci. Merci à toi.
[musique]